>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Pamela Jackson: So, good
morning again, I'm Pam Jackson,
I'm Director for the Center for
the Book and Chair of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards Program,
and I'd like to welcome
you here this morning.
Thank you so much for being here,
being part of the conversation
we're going to have.
We're very excited about who we
have in the room and the ideas
and programs-- the ideas
that are going to be shared
and the programs we're
going to be learning about.
In case you all don't know, we have
representation from as far away
as Afghanistan, and
Ethiopia, Cambodia, Canada,
Maine and right here in New
Jersey, just as an example.
So we've got a wide array
of people and organizations
that we'll be learning
about today, we're very,
very glad to be in
this conversation.
So let me take a few minutes just
to provide a bit of an overview
and then we'll talk
about how the day's going
to go and we'll get started.
First, I would like to just
acknowledge for the Center
for the Book, administers
the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
Program which began in 2013.
And, excuse me-- was a
result of idea generation
by the Founding Director of the
Center for the Book John Y. Cole,
could you raise your hand
so we can acknowledge you?
[ Applause ]
With generous support from David
M. Rubenstein of the Carlyle Group,
as our program developed
over the years,
we have now in our
fourth year awarded prices
to Literacy Organizations.
And there are two ways, there
are Award-Winning organizations.
We have David M. Rubenstein
Prize, the American prize
and the international prize.
And those awards and the
winners will be a part
of the afternoon program.
This morning's program is
the best practice honorees,
and we're very thrilled to have 14
organizations represented today,
who will be sharing about their
practices, their organizations,
the work they are doing to make a
difference in the world of literacy,
providing literacy, expanding
literacy, expanding the ability
and capacity for others
to be literate
or deliver literacy to the world.
And we're very thankful for this.
But, in order to accomplish this
work, we rely heavily on the work
of our advisory board, and I'd like
to acknowledge them, we have a table
of representative if you could
stand to be acknowledged.
We have some of our board of
advisors here with us this morning.
Thank you.
Yes, and if-- feel free
to move, thank you.
So, this group of individuals
provides their expertise in serving
on selection committees
that review the applications
for the awards program,
devoting their time and attention
in committee work to look
at what the practices are,
what the work is that's being
done, how sustainable is it,
how innovative is it, how wide
and deep is the penetration
of the services and making their
selections and doing the work
to have each year's award
winners be chosen from there.
So, we thank you and we honor
you for the work and the time
and the commitment, thank you.
So, I also want to just acknowledge
because we can't--
I don't do it alone.
There are a number of Center
for the Books staff inclu--
and Center for the Book includes not
just administration of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
Program, we also include the Poetry
and Literature Center and
the Young Reader's Center.
And so, staff, for those programs
that have been supporting today are
in the room and I just like
you guys to wave your hands
so I can say thank you, for putting
it altogether, wave your hands.
So we're all-- they're actually
still working, so oh well.
And, kind of another acknowledgement
that we should make is that,
we at the Center for the Book
are a part of the National
and International Outreach
unit at the Library.
It's a one-year old organization, a
creation by the Library of Congress,
specifically for the purpose of
ensuring that the vast, diverse
and rich collections of a library
are out in the world, being shared,
expanded and multiplied, and being
accessible by all everywhere.
And, I have the National
Programs director for the National
and International Outreach
center, Eugene Flanagan with us,
and the Director Jane
McAuliffe of the National
and International Outreach.
So if you could stand to
be acknowledged as well.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
So, we'll get to the
focus, the heart of our--
why we're here which is to
hear not from us but from you.
And we have organizations
that were cited for excellence
and best practice areas
that included outreach
to rural communities,
initiatives and innovations
in providing literacy
in the workplace,
research-based professional
development and the use
of mobile devices to
promote literacy.
Together, the groups that we
honor and celebrate here rep--
have helped millions
of people, worldwide,
to discover the wonders
of literacy and reading.
And we'll have the opportunity
to learn about each of them
and the presentations they'll
make here on the stage,
we're going to be a little
bit rigorous with the time
because we have a lot to hear from,
and they had been given instructions
to be able to share
profoundly, deeply,
powerfully and briefly [laughs].
A little bit more though,
in the back of the room there's
a doorway entrance to LJ 113,
and we have some displays, and
some more information from some
of the organizations and they'll be
prepared on the breaks to be there
and talking and sharing more about
the work that they are doing.
So, we don't-- we actually, highly
encourage and want to make sure
that we emphasize part of the
purpose that we're here for today is
to learn from each other.
But then it also means making time
to talk to each other off stage.
And we'll make sure that
there is time for that.
How the program will go, so this
morning's presentations will be
from the honorees, the best
practices that we'll learn about.
We'll take a break and do
some photo ops and stuff
like that up here at the stage.
Lunch will be in here at noon
but they will be about a 30,
40 minute break, around 11:30,
11:15-ish, maybe if you guys have
to deal with what you
need to deal with
and then come back
at noon for lunch.
And then our afternoon
program begins at 1 o'clock
and we'll actually
have the Librarian
of Congress Dr. Carla
Hayden with us,
and our programs benefactor
David M. Rubenstein to be part
of that celebration of
the award winners to learn
about those organizations and
also to have a brief panel talk.
The afternoon concludes with the
opportunity for more networking,
either an LJ 113 or here in the
room, and/or for those of you
who are interested and
haven't had a chance to do so,
we will provide docent-led
tours of the Library
of Congress, Jefferson building.
So we think that's a very-- it's
just a magnificent place to be.
We're thrilled to share it with
you, and we'll provide tours
to give you a sense of it.
Our 4 p.m. reception is in a
little room which is one level down
and we'll have staff to guide
you, and we'll conclude at five.
And yeah. Get ready [laughs]!
So, as we begin our presentation,
so I want to invite us to listen
in a particular way, and you
have sheets in your folders.
First of all, you do have the
program for the day on the card,
on the top of your photo.
But inside, we actually
have some reflection sheets
and note-taking paper that we have
created with questions for you
to reflect on as you are
listening to the presenters.
And we really want to invite you
to listen a particular kind of way.
We're interested in you,
listening for the big ideas,
listening for the work that you
find most compatible with yours,
listening for the work that
you've never heard of before,
or the ways people
are serving others
and you've never heard of before.
Listen for the best
practices you want to adopt.
Listen for the best practices you
already performed that you want
to refine and enhance, and to
be in conversation about it.
So we have two things going on.
We have the opportunity for you
to have your reflection note
for yourself and those are
meant for you to take with you.
But we also have boards
up in the back
and there is one here
towards the door to LGJ 13,
Vida's raising her
hands, she is near it.
And there is another one
here to my kind of left here,
that are probing questions that
we'd like you throughout the day,
to visit the board, there's
some posted notes and ink pens,
write your notes and leave
them for us on the board.
And there are questions that we
would like to have answered from you
that will help simulate
our ideas and thoughts
about what were the biggest
ideas you heard today.
What are you taking away from today?
What do you want us to know about
what you want to see next from us?
So we invite you to be thinking
about that as you're learning--
listening to and learning
from the organizations.
So both take-- note
taking at your seats
and also visiting the white
boards when you get a chance.
And with that, we'll actually
start our presentations,
let me check on my time, yehey.
All right, great, so and--
so we'll start us off
with Krister Karlsson,
from Ethiopia Reads.
Krister is the Director of
Development for the organization
which is nearly 20 years old.
Their mission is to collaborate
with communities to build schools,
establish libraries, train
educators, boost literacy,
provide youth and families
with the tools
to improve their lives in Ethiopia.
Please welcome Krister Karlsson.
[ Applause ]
>> Krister Karlsson: So I
guess we'll get this started.
My name is Krister Karlsson,
and I'm the Development Director
for Ethiopia Reads, one
of the Literacy Award Honorees
being celebrated today.
I'm proud and humbled to
stand here before you,
and I want to thank
the Library of Congress
for this incredible recognition.
Ethiopia Reads has
been a leader in youth
and children's literacy
for nearly 20 years.
Since 1998, Ethiopia Reads has
built more than 70 libraries
in every region of the country,
shipped more than a
quarter million books,
and serves over 130,000
children every year in rural
and urban communities
throughout Ethiopia.
We build libraries where there
were none, and often partnering
with schools to build classroom
libraries for their students.
And where there were no
schools, we built those two.
However, after building dozens
of libraries in the schools,
we still face huge challenges
promoting literacy in Ethiopia.
After years of working
closely with local communities,
we've finally understood, instead
of building one new library
after another, communities simply
wanted to improve the quality
of reading spaces that
already existed.
So, over 10 years ago,
Ethiopia reads,
shifted toward a more
efficient cost-effective program
by designing projects that were
based on the needs and desires
of recipients, by listening to
the actual people on the ground.
By avoiding top heavy donor-driven
ideas of development and instead,
by emphasizing the needs and
desires of local stakeholders,
Ethiopia Reads has been able
to successfully promote reading
culture throughout Ethiopia,
not just for the thousands of
young students in the classroom,
but for their families and
their neighborhoods too.
Our program, the book-centered
learning program, provides training
and professional development,
so librarians
and educators can gain
critical skills
and feel supported in the workplace.
The Book-Centered Learning
Program incorporates three elements
essential to best practices.
First, professional
training and mentorship,
on-site with regular follow-up.
Second, we collect data on site
which informs the design
of our training program.
This is an ongoing
collaboration between educators
and Ethiopia Reads staff members
in Addis, with short feedback loops
to provide continuous
improvement and innovation.
Finally, Ethiopia Reads is
an institutional advocate
for our teachers and librarians,
giving them greater voice
when working with education
bureaus or government offices
or local school administrations.
The Book Centered Learning Program
has been implemented in 22 schools
across six regions including
Addis Ababa, as well as Southern
and Eastern Ethiopia as well.
This, I suspect is the main
reason Ethiopia Reads is being
recognized today.
Because of our ability to evolve
beyond the brick and mortar concept
of development, past
simply building library,
it's an opening reading
spaces, to embrace the model
of the delivery services
tailored to the needs
of the recipients on the ground.
There are no shortcuts or gimmicks
to addressing youth and
children's literacy.
It simply depends on the hard work
being done on the field combined
with thoughtful planning
that accounts
for local needs and interest.
Our experience teaches
the importance
of a comprehensive literacy model
that addresses issues of access
and awareness with emphasis
on quality of instruction.
Ethiopia Reads has impacted
over 1 million children
throughout the country
and we hope our programs will
serve as a model for the future.
We hope to pave the way for the
next generation of literate parents,
teachers and future
leaders of Ethiopia.
Once again, thank you for this
award today, we look forward
to the bright future
ahead, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: All right.
Let me just pause and just say there
are a couple of people standing
in the back, there are chairs
that are available down front,
so please feel free to join us now.
And also, Tanyella Evans,
could you raise your hand?
Oh hi, Ricardo needs to see you back
there if you could take a moment.
We'll give just a moment to
allow people to be seated,
yeah, thank you, welcome.
All right, great!
So next, we will hear from Paul
Austin of Students and Parents
in Cooperative Education,
also known as SPICE.
SPICE targets families
in Waldo County,
Maine that have children
ages zero through eight,
whose parents have less than a 12th
grade education, a reading level.
Paul is superintendent of
schools for Regional School Unit 3
which comprises 11 towns in Maine.
Please welcome Paul Austin.
[ Applause ]
>> Paul Austin: OK.
Good morning.
If anybody of you who are-- ever
been to Maine, you will realize
that you can get there from here.
It wouldn't be fitting for
me, and I promised my staff
that I would not speak in a
down east accent, I
really don't have one.
And so I'm really sorry for that.
I'll do my best with our PowerPoint.
And given five minutes, it
usually takes me five minutes
to introduce myself.
So, I'll do my best.
A little bit about RSU 3.
First of all, we're located in
western Waldo County, Maine.
We serve 1300 and 50 students
in grades pre-K through 12.
We're comprised of 11 small, very
rural towns, encompassing more
than 440 square miles of
incredibly beautiful farmland
and fields and forest.
I'll skip through a
little bit to save time.
In 2015, to give you a little
snapshot of our district,
72 to 75% of our students qualified
for free and reduced school lunch.
And in 2016, the district that
applied for them was approved
for the Community Eligibility
Program,
meaning that all students receive
free and healthy breakfast,
lunch and snacks everyday.
Students and parents in Cooperative
Education Family Literacy Program
was originated through the
federal Even Start grant in 2000.
And SPICE is now funded by
our local district funds
and for the past 10 years,
through the very generous support
of the Barbara Bush
Family Literacy Foundation.
The SPICE program was based
upon the four component model
of family literacy, adult
literacy where we support parents
in developing the most basic
skills in reading, writing
and numeracy and to
speak in English.
Our early childhood literacy,
we support brain-based
early language development
and pre-reading skills
for infants and toddlers.
Intergenerational literacy,
we offer activities designed
to build literacy-focused
relationships between parents
and children by helping
families recognize and capitalize
on the opportunities to
learn and grow together.
And through parent education,
we help parents become the head
of a literacy rich household,
becoming their children's first
and most important teachers.
We promote their children's speech,
reading and educational development
and to form partnership with
their children's teachers.
Our mission is that the
staff are actively engaged
and support the individual's ability
to read, write and speak in English,
compute and solve problems at levels
of proficiency necessary to function
on the job, in the
family, and in society.
Our core values are
the parents matter.
Parents are the first and
most influential teachers
in their child's life.
Literacy works, parents who build
their own literacy skills increase
their children's success in school.
Success occurs, so the
parental support is critical
for their children's success in
school and that strength enhances
that all parents have strengths
that can be transferred to children
and built upon to increase
skill levels.
Some exciting outcomes
of our program.
Sixty eight percent of the
children served by the SPICE program
over the years have
consistently earned average
to above average test
scores in school.
A student from one of the first
SPICE families recently graduated
in 2012 as the first generation high
school graduate from their family.
The SPICE program serves
very young parents,
including as low as15 years
old, and serves a high number
of children ages birth to three
which is the critical area
obviously of literacy.
And the SPICE program
has consistently scored
over a 90% proficiency
on performance indicators
that are required by local,
state, and federal authorities,
as well as our private foundations
that have fiscally-supported the
program during the past 15 years.
In 2005, SPICE was honored to
become internationally-recognized
and became part of the United
Nations Educational, Scientific,
and Cultural Organization, database
for effective literacy
practices worldwide.
The SPICE "Virtual Learning
Center" which was created in 2011,
won the national 2013 United States
Conference on Adult Literacy,
award for program innovation
and collaboration.
In 2016, we're very honored today
to be "A Best Practice Honoree"
by the Library of Congress
Literacy Awards Program,
supported through the
generosity of David M. Rubenstein,
CEO and co-founder
of the Carlyle Group.
I would end today on behalf of
the board of directors of RSU 3,
the RSU 3 Adult and
Community Education Program
and the SPICE staff, parents
and especially our students.
We want to thank the
Library of Congress
for this extraordinary honor.
We'd also like to take
this opportunity
to express our greatest appreciation
to the Barbara Bush
Family Literacy Foundation
for their continued
generous financial support
for the past 10 years.
SPICE would simply not be possible
without their incredible support.
And I welcome all of you as we
go on today to please feel free
to contact me to speak to me
and we'll talk more about it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank you Paul.
So just a note, I neglected to--
Our presenters have been given
instructions for how the day will go
but I neglected to mention that
the timekeeper's right here.
So keep your eyes on him.
OK, next is Sharon Rawlins,
collaborative Summer Library Program
which is a consortium of
states working together
to provide high quality summer
reading program materials
for children, teens and adult at the
lowest possible cost for libraries.
Sharon is the president of the
board of directors of this program
and is a youth services
specialist in Life Long Learning
at the New Jersey State Library.
Please welcome, Sharon Rawlins.
[ Applause ]
>> Sharon Rawlins:
Good morning everyone.
Thank you so much to the Library of
Congress for this wonderful honor.
We're very every excited.
It was so kindly already mentioned
that our mission and you can click
to the next slide if you like.
It's listed there,
oh left, here we go.
Yes, this is our mission, it's to--
We are consortium of states
which means we are US-wide
and we are all volunteer librarians.
We're library staff members,
so we don't really have a
headquarters although we have
administrative offices in Iowa.
But our main mission is to provide
a unified summer reading theme along
with professional art and
evidence-based materials
so that member libraries can provide
high quality summer reading programs
at the lowest cost.
We have been around
for nearly 30 years
and we are basically a grassroots
movement of several states
in the mid West to decide
that they did not want
to keep reinventing the wheel
when it came to summer reading.
Many of the libraries are small ones
where they only have one staff
member or they have volunteers
who come in, and may not
be librarians or educators.
So we felt that this
would be really helpful
to encourage all the public
libraries in all the states
to get involved in the
Summer Reading Program.
Because as we all know,
summer reading is so important
for the students to
avoid the summer slide.
We provide manuals that target
early literacy, children's,
teens and adults and it has
everything from, example,
reading logs to how to get
your town council involved
and introducing your
summer reading program.
We also collaborate
with our schools.
It's a summer reading program
from public libraries but we know
that schools are doing
their own program,
but we strongly encourage them
to partner, not only with schools
but also with other
after-school organizations.
The theme is selected
by the librarians.
It's a very democratic process.
All 50 states are involved
and everybody gets a vote.
Not only are the 50 states involved
but also we have American Samoa,
Bermuda, the Cayman Islands,
Federated States of Micronesia,
Guam and the Mariana Islands.
And we recently heard that Australia
is interested in joining as well.
We also have a national reading
spokesperson, a reading champion
for the last two years,
it was Kate DiCamillo
and then this year it's
going to be Kwame Alexander.
And the other thing that
probably sets us apart from some
of the other organizations is
we do have a noted illustrator.
The illustrators come to us and
say, can we illustrate your artwork?
And this coming summer for
2017 is Build a Better World
which incorporates stem and steam
and architecture and engineering
and blocks and legos and
all that kind of stuff.
And Dion Mccauley who
many of you may know
for his wonderful the way
things work books that we used
when I started off in libraries
because internet didn't even exist
at that point, so that
was our reference book.
He is our illustrator, national
illustrator for this year.
It's a low-cost program.
We charge a membership
fee for each state
and then there's a minimum amount
for each library within the state
but it's very cost effective
and very easy for libraries
that have one staff
member to get involved.
The manuals have hundreds of program
ideas and that it's really a package
where you just give it to the
library and say here it is.
Then we provide the
art work for them.
All they have to do is use it.
And the same high quality standards
are across the board in every state.
The librarians that write the
manuals are all volunteers,
but they are-- very knowledgeable.
The evidence-based practice is
the fact that we are working
with several communities and
getting their Evidence-Based surveys
to prove that-- definitively
that summer slide does exist
and that the summer reading
program is really helpful.
Measurable amounts is
what I just mention.
And this is really sustainable
because it's the program
that the librarians
are doing anyway.
And we are the one that's
involved with the program.
We are professional librarians
and so, we take the materials ,
we know our libraries, we know our
communities, we know what they're
like and we gather
together and get the ideas
from staff members
throughout the country.
So, it really is a grassroots
movement done by the librarians
for the communities that they serve.
There's 19,000 public
libraries that are involved
and that doesn't even include
the number of students.
One more slide, this is
just a picture of the kids
and what they're doing in the
summer and how much fun they have.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: An
eternity and also very fast.
So our next presenter
is Timothy Ireland.
And I will have to admit
that I've not yet learn how
to pronounce his name very well
without botching it,
so please forgive me.
It's of the Sao Paulo
School Program in Brazil,
which represents a
25-year collaboration
between Brazil's Federal University
and the Construction
Workers Trade Union.
And it's to support
workers education
and to have Literacy
in the workplace.
The programs are actually
often offered at the workplace.
And in some cases, it's the case
of workers live at the work place.
So, the program has reached more
than thousands of illiterate
workers.
And Timothy is a professor at
the University as a specialist
in literacy in education.
Please welcome Timothy Ireland.
[ Applause ]
>> Timothy Ireland: Good morning.
[Foreign Language].
It's always a pleasure to be able to
speak in Portuguese and in English.
And a great honor to be
here at this ceremony
and to represent the Zipfian School.
The Zipfian School is a literacy
and basic education project
for building workers in the
civil construction industry
in João Pessoa.
This just gives you an idea
of the type of a classroom.
I use more, I decided to go for
more photographs to give you an idea
and the feeding of
what the school is
like throughout than
talking so much.
And this is our logo map,
just to give you an idea
where we're situated on the map.
The top left hand corner you
can see the map of Brazil.
And the-- the brown yellow is
the Northeast Region of Brazil.
João Pessoa is the capital of
the state Paraiba and which is one
of the nine states which make up
the Northeast Region of Brazil,
which is historically one
of the most impoverished
regions of the country.
If you could see, Paraiba on one
side, we have Rio Grande do Norte
on the other side Pernambuco.
Pernambuco is the state where
Paulo Freire was born and lived
and practiced for many years before
being exiled and beginning to go
around the world until he return
to Sao Paulo towards
the end of his life.
So, Literacy work in Paraiba's
being very much influenced
by Paulo Freire's thinking of
the last 50 years more or less.
The school-- the Zipfian
School is a partnership
between the Federal University
which is a public university
and the Sintricom and the
Building Workers Trade Union.
And, building trade-- the Building
Workers Trade Union in Brazil--
João Pessoa is one of
the biggest trade unions.
It has about 10,000 members,
has become increasingly strong
over the last 30 years since
a group of workers took over.
This photograph just shows a typical
member of the building works,
trade union and typical
construction work in Brazil.
And we have a poem which is
part of our literacy material.
And which is the translation
is the following.
It says, my name is Benedito.
[Laughter] I was born
in the country side.
I live in the capitol.
Here I work in the
construction industry.
I build tower blocks and houses.
I build bridges and I dig drains.
My hand makes the city grow.
I dream of building a good house,
a house for my family to live in.
So Benedito is very much the
typical student of the project.
The workers are all mainly men.
We have a few women,
but very few women.
They come from the countryside
in search of work in the city.
Most of them were formerly
agricultural workers.
And, this partnership as
you can see the university,
the typical logo mark for university
and the building work
as trade union.
This is being the strongest mark of
the project over the last 25 years.
The university has one agreement
with a workers trade union.
And it's very rare for the
university, as a public university,
to make such an agreement
with a worker's trade union.
So the school offers literacy and
basic education as well of a series
of other activities including health
nutrition, cultural activities,
mobile learning workshops using
tablets and digital media,
access to reading and
books in the building site,
and classrooms are all
situated in the building site.
They take place from nine--
seven until nine, a night from
Monday through to Thursday.
The teachers-- just gives you an
idea of what the building sites are
like in this part of the world.
The teachers are all students
and from the university,
from various courses, from pedagogy,
from literature, we have chemistry,
biology, languages, they
all receive a small stipend.
And the majority are women,
there were very few men.
The object of the scholar to
contribute to the general education
of building worker
and to its formation
as a critical citizen
and trade unionist.
The results-- you can see
the school, and the results
after 25 years of activities more
than 5000 building
workers are being attended
and indirectly their
families as well.
And 400 students have
been trained as educators.
And, we've also produced
textbook material,
numerous academic articles,
and a large number
of master's dissertations
and PhD thesis.
Thank you for your attention.
[Foreign language].
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: As we
move to our next speaker.
We have from GIC police department,
I think we have the representative--
listed is not here and in their
place is going to be Mostafa Ahmadi.
The GIZ police corporation--
cooperation project is a project
in Afghanistan that's established
in response to the low literacy rate
of the Afghan national police,
72% of whom are illiterate.
Please welcome, Mostafa.
[ Applause ]
>> Mostafa Ahmadi: Good
morning ladies and gentlemen.
It's a pleasure to be here and
a great honor to be here today
and to talk about our project, you
know, achievements in what we do
and now we do the literacy
program back in Afghanistan.
I like this picture.
When I see it that motivates me,
when you see the girls and boys,
I mean with the-- these
opportunities that we have back
in Afghanistan in joining
police forces,
not only serving their country
but at the same time they receive,
sort of speak, free education.
Unfortunately, back in
Afghanistan, 62% of--
in general, the population of
illiterate and that affects a lot,
the police, the unit
that they are responsible
to implement rule of
leading the country.
Almost 75% of the police
are illiterate,
50% of the police are semi-literate.
The rest are literate.
We call them the officers.
Yeah. With the objective of
the project is party clear
from the responsibilities
of police as.
Back in the society, we are working
not only to literate them but also
to create a good relation between
the community and the police
and the unit that they are
responsible to implement the rule
of law back in the country
and in the districts.
Currently, the project that,
so to speak, I represent here,
we cover the whole
province of the country.
We are active in 34
province of Afghanistan.
And currently, around the world
30,000 police are participating our
literacy courses on a daily basis.
In general, around
80,000 police have gone
through literacy program
in Afghanistan.
And we have done several surveys
in order to see the impact
and the result of the project.
And the result keeps us
motivated to continue the work
that we do back in Afghanistan.
Because one of the
aim that we have--
we are aiming and focusing
to be the--
to build up a bridge
between community and police
so people can trust the police,
the forces that they are
responsible in their societies.
The photos of the police
you see, they've got a gun
and they've got a notebook.
They are responsible to
implement rule of law,
at the same time they
are willing to learn.
And we were asked for sometimes, of
why you've got a gun and a notebook.
So they are police and
they have to have it
and they have to carry it on.
The project is continual in
coordination with the minister
of education and MOI as partners
in order to have them on board
because of the sustainability
of the project in order
to make the government
be responsible
in the future to run the literacy.
Because with the high rate
of illiteracy that we have
in Afghanistan, it's kind of not
that much of optimistic that in 5
to 10 years, we would produce that
much that police officers or police
that they're going to be recruited,
they'd be able to read and write.
When we say read and write, I know
the new definition for literacy
that we're having now around
the world, that is not the one
that we have it in Afghanistan.
What we mean by literacy is
the whole classic, read, write,
and mathematic, that's what we do.
When we started the
project, of course,
we used the curriculum
of the government.
And in addition to that, in order to
make able police to know their rules
and responsibility as
police in the society,
we added up some additional
topics in our curriculum.
The topics that-- when
I see that-- I like.
It's about human rights.
It's about gender.
It's about the police rules
and responsibility,
healthcare environment.
So they know who they
are and what they do,
and what is their responsible--
one minute.
In addition to that
curriculum, we created
or we upgraded the curriculum that
we have from fourth to sixth grade,
because literacy back in Afghanistan
means that from the first
to third grade of school, since the
police are responsible and they have
to know more about their
roles and responsibility.
We upgraded the curriculum from
four to six grade which means
that once they have gone through
the course, they would be able
to continue further education at
any school they are willing to.
Thank you very much and still
I think I've got a minute.
And also, I've got a news of-- one
of the project that is underway.
Soon it's going to be launched.
One thousand library all over the
country and all police units going
to be sent off pretty
soon which consist
of almost 500 different
topic of books in order
to have small library
and a police unit.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Wow.
Very exciting.
So, thank you.
Next, our honoree from
Cambodia is Sothik Hok of Sipar.
This is a 35 year-old
organization based in Cambodia
that promotes literacy by creating
libraries that can be accessed
by undeserved population accessed.
Their focus is on making
books an educational lever.
Actually, transporting them
and making them accessible
to undeserved populations.
So please welcome, the
director of Sipar, Sothik Hok.
[ Applause ]
>> Sothik Hok: Good
morning everyone.
I have brought two
parts of presentation.
The first is a PowerPoint and
the second will be a small video.
So I will ask if we have for--
so my time so I try to go,
to get it very quickly
with the presentation.
Sipar worked in Cambodia in 25
year, you know, partnership--
partner with the UNESCO education.
So, we start work first in
the school by creating the--
around 300 library in
the primary school.
And we are working
also in the community
by creating a lot of library.
We have mobile library.
We have the library by
backpack for the young volunteer
who are traveling from village
to village to, you know,
to disseminate the
books for the children
and for young people and adult also.
We have a book publishing
program because we are faced
with the big problem of books in
Cambodia, because after 20 year
of all, and the [inaudible]
Khmer Rouge.
We have a lot of problem
with books, we try to level
up books in Khmer language.
So, and we are working now in
community, in prisons, in hospitals.
And the last project we are
running now, and the many project
that allow us to be one of best
practices here is a project
on library for the worker
and garment factories.
You know, a garment factory is, you
know, is a very important sector,
a [inaudible] sector of Cambodia
because its represent 80%
of exports from Cambodia.
So, now I would like to invite
you to watch a small video
about the garment factory.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> I think every managers
or every factories
that can afford it should have one.
[ Music ]
>> Today I'm very happy, because
we are changing from mobile library
to permanent library and the
staff can get more informations
by the book.
And so they can borrow
the books to home to read
for their children before sleeping.
[ Music ]
>> Joel Dionco: The factory
only provides three staff
that Sipar will help them to learn
how to be librarian, and table,
and space for workers
to read and that's all.
[ Music ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Albert Tan: Sipar helps to
provide the books, posters, flyers,
digital pads, and then computers.
[ Music ]
>> Van Soul Leng: The library
resource center helps reduce the
vulnerability of the worker
by giving them the chance
to self-learning and by knowing more
people tend to be more responsible,
they can plan their future.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Music ]
>> Boris Ploum: So the fact
that they read all these
books is also very good
for the work situation because they
will improve their reading skills
which is important for example
reading information that we spread
in the factory or for
filling out forms.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Music ]
>> Albert Teo: It will help our
workers to be more knowledgeable.
It will help them to overcome
whatever issue they might have
at home or even at work.
>> Joel Dionco: Library is now part
of our corporate social
responsibility.
And by providing this
to the workers it shows
to the buyers how we are
really helping our workers.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Music ]
>> Sothik Hok: Thank
you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: That certainly
made it more real, didn't it?
Thank you.
Our next honoree is National
Center on Adult Literacy,
the International Literacy
Institute based in Philadelphia
at the University of Pennsylvania
represented by Dan Wagner.
This organization focuses on
improving literacy policy practice
and professional development
through research.
Dan is a professor in the University
of Pennsylvania graduate school
of education, and was
founding director
of the literacy research center
at the University of
Pennsylvania in 1983.
Since 1990, he served as a director
of the federally-funded National
Center on Adult Literacy,
as well as the director of the
International Literacy Institute.
Please welcome, Dan Wagner.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Wagner: Hello!
Good morning everybody and like the
others, I'm so pleased to be able
to be here at the Library
of Congress,
one of my favorite
institutions in the world.
It's really a pleasure, and
of course, to be with a group
of literacy people comes very close
with my other favorite
professional association.
So, in fact, it's true, 33 years
is almost a lifetime although I did
notice looking through the other
biographies, there are a few of you
who are roughly in the
same gray hair of category.
It's a long haul to
do work in literacy.
Let me just start by saying
that those two acronyms
and logos you see, NCAL
and ILI actually started
with a different one, the
literacy research center
which was started in 1983.
And we did this because
it was our sense
that there was a tremendous amount
of work being done, excellent work,
the kind of work we're
looking at today.
But that the research side
had been largely ignored
at least at major universities.
So we decided to start-- I
think in the United States,
the first lifespan literacy program
from early childhood
through adult education.
We did receive funding from
the department of education
to create NCAL, the national
center, and then a combination
of UNESCO funding and World Bank
and others to create the ILI.
So, just a few highlights
here, just because some
of you might remember there was a--
in the early days of the internet,
an organ-- a platform called
literacy links that we worked
on with KET Television, PBS and
the US Department of Education.
We're actually almost the 10
literacy policy forms here
at the Library of Congress
back in the 1990s,
something I don't think
happens anymore.
But with John Cole, who was
introduced a little earlier,
and his staff, we skipping
a bullet but just to say
that we have organized training
programs for professionals
from nearly 50 countries
around the world,
both in Philadelphia and elsewhere.
And published a wide
variety of material.
I didn't put it on here but
if you go to literacy.org,
pretty easy website to
remember, you'll find many,
many reference materials
and applied research
and development both
nationally and internationally.
Now I thought since I could
do this and as a researcher,
I ought to share with you some
of our most recent findings,
I'm going to give you
a one-minute summary
of what I think is our
favorite current project.
It's called the Bridges
to the Future Initiative.
It is currently running in South
Africa as completed about 10 years
of work in Andhra Pradesh in India.
I'm going to talk mainly about
the South Africa side but just
to show you where we're
talking about, Andhra Pradesh
in southern India and
actually in Limpopo Province is
in the very north part
of South Africa.
The work in India focused on
out of school girls and women.
The South Africa project
focused on kids,
largely although we
also worked with adults
in their adult education
program in South Africa.
All this work is actually
done in partnership
with local NGOs and
with the government.
In the case of India under Pradesh
and in the case of South Africa,
the National Department of Education
and the Provincial Department.
So, South Africa like many of the
countries even today, talking today
and when you go to
international meetings
like UNESCO meetings have
a common set of problems,
these are the ones we are
noting in South Africa that is--
there are literacy
needs across the board
from early childhood
through adulthood.
There are-- I'm sorry,
there's a typo there.
It's not a 111 languages in South
Africa it's only 11, only 11.
And there're all kinds of problems
in South Africa, education.
So this is what our project
looks like on the ground.
I'm not showing a video
today because of the--
just the time limitations.
But you get a sense of the
kids who were in first,
second and third grade here
who are incredibly motivated
and eager to try out our program.
What is interesting
about the program,
just one technical
point here is that,
if you go internationally even
here in the United States,
of course there are kids who
speak different languages
in the same classroom or
in different classrooms.
Part of the goal in our program was
to provide multi-lingual
Literacy on a single platform.
So you had a choice of learning
in either three African
languages or in English.
You could toggle back and forth.
It's a very interesting
innovative program.
I'm going skip this.
It works, just to show
you some data.
I don't have time to tell you
what curves you're looking at,
but it does work.
And we are planning to expand in
South Africa and elsewhere in Africa
and probably in South Asia as well.
So, my time is up and
thank you very much.
If you need to contact me, same
email address, the last three or so.
So, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Perfect.
Thank you Dan.
So, we did have the video and you
made reference to bringing a video
and we know that kind of the faces
make the experience a little more
real for us.
What is life like being illiterate?
And what kind of world
we get to live
in when there's a hundred
percent literacy in it?
Do you want that?
So, we're actually
going to take our break.
So we budgeted a 15-minute window
for us to do a couple of things.
And we before we get up, let me
just do-- let me just say this,
there are a few board members-- the
advisory board members that came
in that we didn't get to acknowledge
at the beginning and Christy's one,
if you could just raise
your hand and say hi.
And was there somebody else that
we didn't get to acknowledge?
OK, great.
So, welcome.
We also want to ask you to remember
to take your reflection notes.
And we invite you to
refresh your beverages
and refresh your breakfast.
And also take a few
minutes to dialogue.
We'll reconvene at 10:30 with the
second half of the presentations.
Thank you so much.
So, we will resume again and we have
Diana Coben of the National Centre
of Literacy and Numeracy for Adult.
And she's with her colleague.
Yes, I'm sorry?
Nicola McCurr-- sorry, McCartney.
The Centre supports Literacy
and Numeracy promotion efforts
in New Zealand and internationally
by providing professional
development training,
disseminating research and
engaging with policymakers.
Diana has been the Director
of the center since 2011
and is an emeritus professor
at King's College London,
where she is a professor
of Adult Numeracy.
Welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Diana Coben: Thank you Pam and
thank you very much the Library
of Congress for this honor, we
are most delighted to be here.
And it's a great pleasure to hear
about all the work
that's being on it today.
Thank you for letting
us to be part of this.
I'm Diana Coben as Pam as said.
And the National Centre is based
at the University of White Castle.
We're funded primarily by
the New Zealand Tertiary
Education Commission.
We build capability in Adult
Literacy and Numeracy Education
through researching for
professional development research
and critical engagement with
policy and practice at the national
and international levels.
Our approach is evidence-based
and we're guided by our own
and of other's research
and scholarly literature especially
its professional expertise
in Adult Literacy and Numeracy
Education, and our knowledge
of the national international
environment for Literacy
and Numeracy Education which I think
is well represented here today.
Without more ado, I'm going to hand
over to my colleague associate
director Niki McCartney
and we're going to show you a
short video and then Niki's going
to explain some of what we do,
because we think that's
more important what we do
than who we are.
>> Nicola McCartney: New Zealand is
in the center of the South Pacific.
And as you can see,
we're not Australia
but we're quite close to Australia.
That's it, that's that little
country in the very middle there.
We're surrounded by sea and as
such, we are very aware or ripples
and we are very aware of ripples
when they see a motion change.
We think we have a couple of good
evidence-based practice ripples
that we would like to
talk to you about today.
The first one is a--
talking about the approach
that New Zealand has taken to
embedded literacy and numeracy.
Whereby at the National Centre, we
are charged with upskilling tutors.
We place trainers with how to
teach literacy and numeracy
at the same time as the
teaching the vocational programs
at the same time.
So, this short video, I really
don't know what's [inaudible] of it
because we know time
is what gives us.
It simplifies out evidence-based
practice
of embedded literacy and numeracy.
Specifically, as it points out how
our approach is contextualized.
It is explicit and transparent.
And it is woven through the training
so that we at teaching literacy
and numeracy with literacy and
numeracy occurs with in the program.
Therefore we have double
aims literacy and numeracy
and vocational aims and out--
double outcomes literacy and
numeracy and vocational outcomes.
>> A manufacturing company is like--
we have a thing that's called the
probable manufacturing value it's--
if everything goes right, how much
money they can make say, in a shift?
All right.
Well, if you look here, this is an
average probable manufacturing value
for a night out shift.
Now, it's overall it's just scale.
Every centimeter on here
represents a thousand dollars.
Tell us how many thousand
dollars the company could aim
from your hard work
in a night hour shift.
>> OK. So 80-- we got 80 thousand.
>> OK. So, does what
the company gets?
Eight-hour shift, your hard work.
That doesn't get to keep it all.
You got paid for your logs.
Now, you know, the
price of logs goes up
and down as you might have had.
This is about an average
log prize for the last year.
>> Nicola McCartney: So that
just gives you an example
of how we approach a bit of
literacy and numeracy, is--
are depended by a framework
called the three knowings,
and we have these three
circles, know the demands,
know the learners and
know what to do.
And supporting that is what we
have as learning progression.
So when we're talking about knowing
the demands, we have progressions
of competencies, we
have an assessment tool
for knowing the learner and
then we have this wonderful seed
of resources for knowing
what to do for the tutors.
And once we know the demands by
mapping the demands of the program
and by the learning assessment tool,
that we can then know what to do.
And as an example, we have
different steps from one to six.
Step four here shows what--
somebody can do from reading,
and step five here shows what
somebody can do for numeracy.
The second-- the second
ripple is to do
with the whole organization
approach.
We talked about learner
literacy and numeracy outcomes,
but we can only do that if we
have seen the management by them.
And for that, we need
to have the three levels
of the embedded framework--
theoretical framework, the learner,
the program and the organization.
The organization is a
self-assessment process
with seeing new management to
identify critical collections
from processes and systems
within the organization.
So from that, we can develop
a strategic action plan
and then implement the literary
numeracy advisory that's required
for that organization.
Diana you want to finish off?
>> Diana Coben: Just very briefly,
as the slide says it was one
of the most active countries
in the world with regard
to policy development in this
area, and the most important thing
with the next slide coming I hope.
Is to help New Zealand adults
reach their skills potential,
I'll just end with a wonderful Maori
saying here which translates as,
"What is the greatest
thing in the world?
It is the people, it is the
people, it is the people.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank
you Diane and Niki.
The Chicago Literary Alliance is
represented today by Alison Hanold
who is the alliances
partnerships director.
The alliance was established in
2009 to encourage collaboration
and resource sharing among Chicago
area literacy organizations.
The centerpiece of that
program is the Literacenter,
a 41,000 square foot space, that can
be shared by many literacy groups.
So please welcome Alison
and her colleague, Stacy.
[ Applause ]
>> Alison Hanold: We're
tag team in it today.
>> Stacy Ratner: Yeah.
>> Alison Hanold: It's not just a.
>> Stacy Ratner: Hi,
there are two of us.
This is Alison and I'm Stacy.
Alison is the partnerships director
of the Chicago Literacy
Alliance, I'm the co-founder.
We're going to tell you in four
and a half minutes what we do,
why we do and where we do it.
I got my start my literacy
10 years ago
when I founded a small organization
called Open Books in Chicago.
And one of the first
schools we worked
at was Schiller Elementary,
this is Schiller.
In a notoriously challenged
part of our city.
At the height of its power,
Schiller had about 250 students.
I was working there for about a
year and then I called a meeting
of other literacy organizations that
I knew, that my friends knew to talk
about how we could work together
and make a bigger difference
in the city.
Imagine my surprise and
disappointment to discover
that all 19 of our organizations
were working at Schiller.
We did not know the
others were there.
Reading scores at Schiller were
not only low , they were dropping,
because frankly it was
oversaturated with resources,
and we were having a negative effect
on the very cause we were
trying to accelerate.
That was the moment
that was the founding
of the Chicago Literacy Alliance.
We can go farther together and
not worry about what's happening
in one place because we have a
goal to change the whole city.
My background before literacy was in
high tech venture founded startups.
And one of the things you get in
that community is shared workspace.
So I suggested that we should have
a shared workspace just for literacy
in the city of Chicago for all us
to get together and know each other,
do more work, a modest
proposal for 41,000 square feet
of shared workspace in
the city of Chicago.
It took a mere three years to get
there, but we did open last May,
this is our front door of our
place with 18 founding members.
Despite says 95, now it's
actually 96 as of last night,
Alison will tell you how we've
quintupled in little more
than a year, and why
we do what we do.
>> Alison Hanold: The goals of
the Chicago Literacy Alliance are
to build community,
capacity and collaboration
for Chicago's literacy
organizations.
Our members cover our missions
from early childhood development
up to adult literacy, work
force development et cetera.
We do that-- excuse
me, by leading programs
that address all three
of those focus areas.
To build capacity, we host on
conferences, on a by-monthly basis
that focus on sharing best practices
in certain administrative areas.
We also host workshops where
members share new literacy tactics
and curriculum with other members.
We build community every single
way that we possibly can.
We do believe that partnerships
begin with relationships.
And so we have a regular
band poetry contest.
We have monthly birthday parties.
We have rock band night
and many more.
I couldn't possibly actually
list all of them right now.
And we believe that building
capacity and community leads
to collaboration and we
also do a number of efforts
to insight effective partnerships
that includes matchmaking.
We host monthly confabs which is
where we're bringing
members together
to share what they're
working on and think
about how they might
partner on a monthly basis.
And we host an annual symposium,
where we talk about what's happening
in the literacy field
in the city as a whole
and how we might be
connecting the various efforts
to address our literacy problems.
Our space, is the home
for illiteracy in Chicago,
it's where all of these
programs take place.
Stacy mentioned that is
just 41,000 square feet.
It has 16 conference rooms and
program rooms that members can use.
It offers office space and cubicles
at 70% less than market rate
in the city in the neighborhood.
It offers co-working space and there
is a used bookstore in the space.
It is functional and fun.
We believe that work should be fun.
We believe that staff with time
morale are much more effective
in addressing the mission
of their organizations.
Our space is covered in puns.
Every conference room is named
after a famous work of fiction
with the word room, somehow in the
name including cats are in the room,
"Wuther Room Heights",
"Roomkenstein",
"Roomeo and Juliet", et cetera.
We have scooters that everyone
can ride around the space.
They also have pun names
including Sir Walter Scoot
and that's Scoot Fitzgerald.
And there are just
bright colors everywhere.
We are evidence of
that as you can see.
And essentially, our space is
Disney World for weird nerds.
All of this fun is by design.
We believe that culture eats
strategy for breakfast and we want
to make sure that people can
collaborate by feeling relaxed,
by letting down their
competitive walls
and really connecting
with an open mind.
We have some success stories.
Illinois does not have
a state budget,
I don't know if you know that,
and that has affected adult literacy
programs quite significantly.
Literary Chicago is the oldest
adult literacy program in the city.
It was on the brink of shutting
down due to the budget crisis
by moving the Literacenter, it cut
85% of its administrative budget
and now host all of
its programs in space.
Chicago Hopes for Kids does
in shelter literacy tutoring
for homeless youth, they
never had a stable office.
By moving into the space, they
were able to raise thousands
of dollars due to the
legitimacy of the space
and they've doubled their staff.
And we are creating
efficiencies for organizations,
Open Books, as an acre tenant.
There you save an annual $100,000
a year by moving into the space
which all of those funds are now
rededicated into their programs.
So please, come visit us
next time you're in Chicago.
>> Stacy Ratner: Or
bring much [inaudible].
>> Alison Hanold: Yes, thank you.
>> Stacy Ratner: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Yeah, so we
could use a little more fun.
[ Laughter ]
Wow, scooters in the
Library of Congress.
I'm game.
[ Laughter ]
Next, to present is Jessica
Rothenberg-Aalami and she is
from Cell-Ed who uses
a mobile first approach
to deliver literacy services
through basic cellphones,
to initiate a session,
users call a central number
and listen to a spoken lesson.
Jessica is the chief executor
and co-founder of Cell-Ed.
So please welcome her.
[ Applause ]
>> Jessica Rothenberg-Aalami:
Good morning everyone.
It's an absolute honor to be
here among literacy luminaries.
As you heard, I am
Jessica Rothenberg-Aalami.
I'm the CEO and the co-founder of
Cell-Ed where we bring literally--
literacy skills to anyone
with a mobile phone, and why?
As you know, over 800 million adults
are non-literate in the world.
Two out of three are women,
like Lucia who before
starting Cell-Ed have less
than a first-grade level
of education in her 40's.
After four months on our program,
not only did she learn to read
and write, she asked for more.
And that's why we designed English
on the go, vocational skills,
health, financial literacy
and other courses because one
in four Americans lack functional
and other essential skills
to navigate daily life.
This is an incredible challenge
for all of us to overcome.
There's so many reasons
barriers exist.
Less than 5% of adults
have access to classrooms.
Less than a third have
access to the internet.
And even if they do have access
to the classrooms often the content
is just not relevant to their needs.
And really, that's why we
get personal at Cell-Ed.
We want to know.
We want to understand which each and
every one of our learner is needing.
What is their specific
learning paying point?
What are their goals
for their learning?
And we can do this on any
mobile phone we can discover.
And be with each and every learner
where they're at and grow with them.
So that makes us disruptive.
Because we need each learner where
they're at and offer them an access
on any mobile phone,
simple feature to smart.
And provide them a life coach.
They can have a two-way conversation
to make sure goals are reached.
We are a bit different in our space.
We're also disruptive because--
and feel we can meet the needs
of low-literate learners.
We are a women and
minority-owned tech company.
We're also a content design company.
And we bring with us a lot
of experience over 20 years
in the field of trying to
bring relevant affordable
and accessible technologies
in over 50 countries.
And we're interdisciplinary.
That's what's required.
We have too many PhDs on staff.
I'm trying to remedy that.
We have community practitioners,
teachers that we rely
on bilingual educators, native
speakers and we ourselves have
to hold to our own ethic.
We are all mobile first as well.
We are distributed team across
Canada and the United States.
And we have done this
work in over 50 countries.
And we are so honored to
be able to do this work
across the United States today.
We have right now over 20,000
on our system a little bit more
than what we have in our program
here for you and we look--
we hope to reach millions more
obviously to our great partnerships.
Because again, we are just a
click, text or phone call away.
Learners appreciate Cell-Ed for a
few different reasons they tell us.
One, that it's available any time,
in just three minutes or less,
they can get a lesson
audio that they listen
to in the two-way texting
and can reach their coach.
So they can do this in
between on their lunch break,
when picking up the children.
They can also let us know
what more they need to learn,
so that we could tailor
their learning.
And so in this way, we're told
that it's been a God-send.
I can now study in the middle of the
night where my kids are sleeping.
I can now do it when I'm on my bus,
if I have two to three
rides to get to school.
We're flexible.
I mentioned the course catalogue
that we have, but we also adapt
and customize our content
to our incredible partners.
For example, with the
state of New York,
we can provide customized
audio lessons and texts that go
out to our [inaudible] farm
workers, and other folks who are
on our system there for the
largest labor union the SEIU.
We can for their health workers
customize some other content.
And then it could become
available to up
to a million members
very quickly and easily.
It's a very adaptable,
flexible platform.
And we have a back end, so we can
track learner progress in real time.
And we do every 30 days a rapid
prototyping and iteration models,
so that we improve our
program and service
and direct response
to learner needs.
We think it's about time
to give adult learners the best
we have to offer in Ed-tech.
And we hope we're doing this and
taking a step in that direction
by making it fully accessible
universal access on any, you know,
to our courses by any mobile phone
and small bits of information
that can be gained in
a few minutes a day,
any time of the day is
our way of doing that.
We also make sure you know
that small is very effective.
People don't have the time
to get to a classroom.
They don't have an hour.
But in a couple minutes if you
can gain the skill you really need
and want, you can make to the next
rung of your own education goals.
We're learner-directed.
We're mobile first but
we're learner-directed.
It's most important for us to
understand the needs of each
and every one of our learners
and to respond to them.
And our partner networks
who've been very fortunate
to have large scale
partnerships from local to global,
but most importantly,
with each of our learners.
And with that, I certainly
hope you will join us
in mobilizing literacy
skills for all.
Thank you again for the
honor and to be among you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: There's such a
diversity in the program activities
of the organizations
we're meeting today.
It's really, really fabulous.
Very inspiring.
And just, I hope gives us the sense
of the power and the magnitude
of what we can accomplish.
Next up. Library for
all is represented today
by Tanyella Evans whose organization
provides an online digital library
provided to children and
developing countries.
The platforms works well on standard
telephones, tablets and computers
and is designed to be used
in low-bandwidth areas.
Tanyella is a co-founder and CEO.
Welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Tanyella Evans:
Thank you so much.
So our mission at "Library
For All" is
to make knowledge accessible
to all equally.
Sounds audacious, right.
Especially in a time that we live
in where 215 million children
across the developing world
are not learning the basics
of how to read and write.
Yeah, at "Library For All" we
are optimistic about the future.
Like many of you here,
we know that six
of the seven billion mobile
phone subscribers live
in developing countries.
And we see this as
a huge opportunity
to change the situation
that we currently face.
At "Library For All," we've
built a digital library platform
that makes Ebooks accessible
in low bandwidth environments
on low-end devices including mobile
phones, tablets and in a browser.
In building the library with
pilots in five countries,
we've made some remarkable
discoveries.
Firstly, as my colleague
mentioned earlier in the research,
mother tongue books are the most
popular books in our library,
not only because they
increase literacy but actually
because there is a huge
demand for those books.
This is our library platform.
This is graph from
our pilot in Cambodia.
We noticed initially in the
pilots that there was an increase
in reading but after about two
months, reading started to drop off.
And we ask our partners,
"what's happening?
What's going on at the schools?"
They told us that the children
in the schools had read
every single combined book
on the library in just a few months.
So this is obviously a big
challenge but also an opportunity.
So, we know that we must work
to fill the virtual shelves
of this digital library
with relevant content,
especially in the mother tongue.
Secondly, we learned that "Library
For All" is having positive
unintended consequences
on children's outlook on their life.
For example, one of our
partners in Haiti works
with former child slaves.
It's a practice in Haiti
that still continues today.
And of the child advocates
Samuel told us about Jerry.
When Jerry started the program, he
was so shy that he wouldn't read
at all, he wouldn't read in front
of his class and he was embarrassed
that he didn't know how to read.
Now today, Jerry is
so motivated to get up
and read aloud in front
of his class.
And he just shared
with us just the change
in his self-esteem
and his confidence.
And this is the power
of reading, right.
This is the power of books
that we all know the ability
to just change a boy's life,
a young boy's life in Haiti
in the programs that
we're working in.
So, there is so much we
can learn about readers
in the developing world
to better serve them.
We are delighted to be on our
tier today for our practice
with many organizations in the
field that we know and respect.
There's no way that we could
undertake this work alone.
And I'm here fortunately also with
my board chair Philippa Tyndale,
she's come from Australia.
So which is not New Zealand we know
but she also has a wonderful accent.
So please and speak to her.
We're based in New York
but we have a global team.
And we invite all of
you also to become--
to be a part of a convening
that we're going
to bring together early
next year with our partners
at the New York public
library to talk
about how we can achieve
this audacious goal.
How we can scale up the plans to put
library in the hands of every person
on the planet regardless of
geography, income or ability.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank you, Tanya.
Well it's not lost on me that your
presentation was on your phone.
I'm still in the paper days.
Allison Kavanagh from
Rumie Initiative.
It's a Canadian organization
that provides children
with mobile tablets.
They are preloaded
with lessons and books.
The books are sold at cost to NGOs
and partner organizations worldwide.
And Allison is head of
operations for Rumie.
Please welcome her now.
[ Applause ]
>> Allison Kavanagh: Thank you.
Hello everyone.
I just want to start up by saying
what an honor it is to be here today
to be able to tell you
about our work at Rumie.
We were founded n 2013 so,
we're a fairly young company
but we have done a lot in the short
period of time and I'm really happy
to be able to tell you about it.
So what we do is we work
to organize the mass
of free-learning content
available online and deliver it
to the people who need it most.
And how do we do that?
Well, with technology of course.
When we saw that a tablet
hardware was available for $50,
and all of this content
was available for free,
we knew that there was a
new solution to education
that could leapfrog over traditional
libraries and help bring access
to education to everyone
around the world.
I want to play a short video
to show you one of our projects
which actually takes
place in Toronto
to teach English to
newcomers to Canada.
OK. So the video didn't work.
But, it is available on our
Facebook and on our YouTube channel.
So, if you have a chance to
see it, it's really inspiring.
So the two economic trends
that we based our model off
of are free digital leaning
content and low hardware costs.
We're also inspired by
one company, Wikipedia.
In a short period of time, Wikipedia
use technology and the wisdom
of the crowd to create something
that used to cost thousands
of dollars completely for free.
So now anyone can go online and
access an Encyclopedia for free
and learn essentially anything
what they want to know.
And by engaging the crowd to create
that, they were able to do it
in an astoundingly
short period of time.
Inspired by Wikipedia, we created
a website called the LearnCloud,
which is an online platform
where we're organizing all topics
of learning content
into lesson plans.
So you can go online and find the
top-rated content in any subject
and actually use it yourself.
This is available as an
application and it's also
where we find the content
to put on our tablets.
Best of all, we engage people
to help us source content
for the tablets.
So for all of our projects, we'll
list the topics that we're looking
for and then engage teams of
students at universities including
at George Washington University here
in DC to actually find this content.
Then we worked with
NGOs around the world
who are already running programs on
the ground to actually, you know,
make sure that all the content fits
their needs, matches their syllabi
and it's appropriate
for their local context.
And by working with
existing frameworks
and engaging skilled volunteers,
we've been able to expand
to 20 countries in
less than three years.
And here are some photos
from our projects.
Some of our projects include
students in Liberia who used
to be child soldiers and
are now being rehabilitated
to learn vocational skills,
English and healthcare knowledge.
Other projects include programs
for Syrian refugees and Turkey
and Lebanon, where millions
of children are at risk
of becoming a lost generation.
We're also doing programs in Canada.
In the city of Toronto where
students don't have great access
to education or after school
programs, as well as in north,
where students don't have
access to the internet
and are therefore losing out
on a lot of this knowledge
that we take for granted.
We measure impact through
technology.
So with our tablets, we have
device analytics that track impact
in individual student progress.
Here's a picture of
a child in Guatemala
where we're running a literacy
program in rural schools
for students to learn how to
read and write in Spanish.
We've heard great, great
feedback from this project and one
of the most exciting
features in my opinion is
that these students are bringing
the tablets home to teach their--
to read with their younger siblings,
their parents are often illiterate,
and essentially making reading a
part of the family environment.
Here's Haya [assumed spelling] who's
a Syrian refugee living in Turkey.
And some of the impact that
we've seen in our project
with Syrian refugees is that not
only are the resources helping
improve numeracy and
literacy outcomes,
but they're also inspiring
kids to come out of their shell
and socialize more with a
positive impact on mental health.
They're also lettings
schools take on more students
within their existing capacity
which is extremely necessarily
with the size of the problem there.
And they're also letting students
both work and go to school
on their own time, so
they don't have to choose
between supporting their family
and pursuing their education.
And finally, with the
analytics, we can be sure
that girls are getting access
to the resources as much
as their male counterparts.
Thank you for very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Wow.
So one of the-- again, one
of our best practice areas
is mobile devices and use
of them in promoting literacy.
It's just amazing to see
what's possible really is.
So, our next presenter,
New York City,
Department of Homeless Services
represented by Karen Shaffer.
The department has established
30-shelter-based libraries
to make reading materials and
educational activities available
to children and families
who lived in shelters.
And these libraries served
about 4,900 children.
Karen is the director
of Homeless Services.
Please welcome her
and her colleague.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Shaffer: Good morning.
We are so honored to be here today.
I'm joined with my
colleagues, Susana Vilardell.
We are extremely excited because as
others have said, partnerships is
so important in resonating
throughout today's events.
And I think one of our tremendous
partners has been from Scholastic,
I saw Korina Palin [assumed
spelling] here today,
vice president.
And we thank her so
much for her support.
Our project actually came
out of the Mayor's office.
Mayor de Blasio had created the
children's cabinet comprised
of 24-city agencies that actually
had brought together different
initiatives concentrating
on children's needs.
And one of the key initiatives
of course was literacy.
And we had launched our
library project in 2014,
and I'll let Susana
explain more about it,
but it has been a very
exciting year.
Thank you.
>> Susana Vilardell: Hi everyone.
My name is Susana Vilardell.
I'm the director of
educational services
at the Department of
Homeless Services.
So-- And such an incredible
huge system as New York City,
we have 20,000 students
living in temporary house
and residing in our shelters.
And we are think-- we thought
about what would be the best way
to bring literacy resources to our
shelters where there is of course,
resources and what would be the best
way to create a sustainable program.
So this is how the family
shelter library pilot was created.
The goal was to really
increase literacy resources
to all our shelters.
We started with 20 shelters,
we're now at 30 shelters.
We increase the number
of books all donated
by various partners
such as Scholastic.
We also had a relationship with
New York City Service to partner
with them to bring volunteers to
provide services to the children
because our shelter directors
are obviously very busy trying
to help families move
into permanent housing.
So there is not a lot
of staff in the shelters
to support the unique needs of
students in temporary housing.
Also, part of the goal was
to link our shelter staff
and families to the local braches.
So we've partnered with
New York public library,
the Brooklyn public library
and the Queens public library.
The librarians for the different
branches near to the shelters,
visited the shelters once a
week or maybe once a month
to create various events such
as library cards, reading--
read alouds and other, you know,
opportunities for also
parents to be involved.
And we also-- As part of this pilot,
we wanted to have a very strong
focus on education because children
who are in temporary housing
perform absolutely much less
than their permanently house peers.
They don't do well in math but
specifically they don't do well
in reading, into the ELA testing.
So that's why we wanted
to focus on reading.
Some of the successes that we have
with our program, it's expanding
because we have invited more
partners to be part of this effort
such as the Department of Education.
We partnered with various--
with Scholastica as we mentioned
and now we-- the Scholastica
has donated
over 3000 books to our Shelters.
We also worked with other-- the
private sector to give book cases,
book shelves to the Shelters
to create their libraries.
And also, we invited the
community to be part of this pilot.
As I said we recruited
volunteers through the community.
And we also partnered
with St. John's University
to create volunteer opportunities
at one of our shelters.
Through these partnerships
with the local libraries,
we were able to bring and promote
technology and computer access
because a lot of the
shelters don't have computer,
so the families would be able to
go to access a computers there.
You can see all the
successes here in the screen.
Here are some photos of our program
of our event and the goal also was
to increase literacy for
babies because our parents,
the head of cases in the shelters,
half of them don't even
have a high school diploma.
So they're not going to be
able to read to their babies.
And this of course creates
an issue with baby vocabulary
when they're going to Pre-K they
have, you know, a disadvantage
in comparison to the
rest of the children.
Finally, we created our
Family Shelter Library Toolkit
to provide the shelters, you know,
to empower them to create a library
in their building so what
would that look like, you know,
to create a mission
statement, acquire materials,
program services et cetera.
So we're very excited to be here.
These are our contact information.
We would love to partner with you
and looking forward to meeting all
of you for the rest of the day.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Wow,
20,000 homeless children.
So we're actually winding down
towards our last presenter but one
of the things I wanted to
mention, a couple people had asked
for the opportunity to have a
bit of a dialogue, and so we do--
we will have time for that after
our last presenter, an opportunity
to have a quick Q&A and I'll
just kind of be across the room.
So for those of you who had
been wondering and speculating
and wanting to ask
somebody something who is
at the microphone earlier, your
chance to do so is coming shortly.
But first, let me introduce
Nancy Dupree
of the Afghanistan Center
at Kabul University.
The Center was founded in 1989 in
Pakistan to serve Afghan refugees
and it's now based at Kabul
University serving both refugees
and those living in Afghanistan.
Nancy is the director of the center.
Please welcome her.
[ Applause ]
>> Nancy Dupree: Good morning
or good afternoon everybody.
It's a pleasure to
be invited to speak
in this very [inaudible] setting.
I'm very honored and
pleased to be with you.
My proud chart is a box libraries
that are filled with about 200--
originally, with 200
books and they go
out into the rural
areas of Afghanistan.
I got this idea when we were working
with the refugees in Pakistan.
And I noticed that in the schools,
the students were receiving lots
of history, Arab history, Pakistani
history but no Afghan history.
And this were it may because I
thought these young people were not
developing any sense of
belonging to Afghanistan.
They didn't know about
their culture.
their environment.
And I thought when they return
this would be disastrous
because they were also not allowed
to farm in the refugee camps.
So these were rural people,
rural young people going back
to rural areas without knowing how
to take care of any kind of farming.
So, we created in 1996, something
called a Boxed Library Extension.
We publish books there
for new literates.
There are lots and lots of literacy
courses, too many literacy courses
and when you ask them
what did they give them
to read, not by mandate I said.
I said sir, you know,
if you'll change them
and then you don't give them
something to read, they are going
to lose this skill that they are--
and all your work will
fail, not by mandate.
Well, I though it was
by mandate so we started
and we established a committee
to supervise the production
of small books, no more than a
100 pages which got us into a lot
of trouble in the beginning
because the authors would say,
my subject, I need 500 pages.
But if you give a new
literate 500 page book,
they're not going to touch it.
But a 100 pages with nicely
illustrated, they will pick up.
And we have now 252 of these mobile
libraries out in the countryside,
in the provinces and all 34
provinces of Afghanistan.
Some of the provinces
don't have them.
Only have one or two because
the security is still too bad.
But the 252 are accountable for able
150,000 books that are out there
where there no were
any books before.
And we get all kinds of
enthusiastic letters,
because providing knowledge
is important.
And encouraging the culture
of reading is also important.
There's nobody there before
because there weren't any books.
However, there is one dimension
which most of the people working
in Afghanistan and that that is
the books create an improvement
and enhancement of
confidence, their ego boosted.
And I think that is
very, very important.
For instance, there was
one man who wrote to us
and said his orchard
was not doing very well.
And then he got an aid book
that taught him about grafting,
taught him about trimming, taught
him about irrigation, fertilizer
and now his or orchard is
blooming and above that,
he has become the expert
of his province.
People come from all over
the province to consult him
and that's certainly ego-boosting.
Donors always ask us,
what's your impact?
They want statistics.
Well, I can tell them how many
books we have out there and so
and so forth, but though one high
school girl said her illiterate
family asked her to bring books
home so she can read to them
and the neighbors pass on
the information to neighbors
and they have a great
time discussing the books.
So I think that our project is only
a drop in the bucket obviously.
But there are other
NGO, if not others.
I'm not an NGO.
Well, other if-- there are
other NGOs that are following,
buying our books, following
our system,
so I have no idea how many
books but it is just many,
many thousand where there
were no books before.
So we thank you very much for
your support and thank you
for listening to us today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Wow.
So she said, ego boasting and
what I heard most is empowered.
>> Yeah.
>> Pamela Jackson: Just what it
means to certain people young
and old to be empowered,
to live lives of choice,
because they can read.
Wow. Sorry, some of these
folks know I cry all the time.
This program and this work
is so moving and so powerful.
And I'm just thrilled to be
in this conversation with you.
And, now it's time to ask questions.
So, we have two microphone
runners, Ania [assumed spelling]
and Ricardo come forward.
They will-- if you have a
question, raise your hand,
they're going to bring you
the mic and Vida is going
to actually bring the
mic the person you would
like to ask the question of.
So who's got a question?
Yes, Timothy.
So Timothy who's your question for?
>> Timothy Ireland: Library for all.
>> Pamela Jackson: Library for all,
so Vida if you could come this way
and bring the microphone to
Tanyella that would be great.
Isn't on? OK, is yours on?
>> Timothy Ireland:
It's very interested--
it's been a fascinating morning.
Then the desire to talk with
everybody afterwards and to be able
to build bridges and to be able
to delve into the experiences
which are being presented, but
I was particularly interested
in the question of
the digital library.
We've been working on the
digital library for workers,
or for people who are with low
reading and writing skills,
such as the ideas to have a library
which doesn't depend on reading
on having words as classifications.
So I'd be very interested
to know in what--
when you talk about your digital
library, isn't meant for people
who already read and write or for
those who don't read and write
and a little more about so that
we couldn't stop the conversation.
>> Tanyella Evans: Absolutely.
Thank you for the question.
You know, it's really
interesting that you've raised
that because I think that we see
ourselves as part of the solution.
I didn't touch on this but
we don't give out devices,
we don't really implement our
own programs except in Haiti
where we started and
wanted to learn.
So we always work in
partnership with organizations
that are focused on literacy.
Actually, we worked
with Sipar in Cambodia.
We worked through the First
Lady's Foundation in Rwanda.
She is focused on creating
a culture of reading.
So I think that the library--
we see ourselves kind of a--
almost as a service provider if you
are focused on providing literacy,
but don't have content in
local languages for example
or even English or French.
We have a lot of international
languages as well,
then Library For All is a resource
for you to do your work better.
So for example in Haiti, we
have the largest collection,
now digital collection of
content in Haitian Creole,
we have a large collection
in Kenya-Rwanda.
And we see our role as partnering
with libraries in country as well
as here to digitize content
and make that available.
Although, we don't think
that we will ever become
a self-learning platform.
We do want to start
incorporating technology
that will enable more
self-learning and more support
for those with early literacy.
So very simply, we could
start with audio, right?
Audio can also-- holds a lot a
promise because it can be used
in low bandwidth environments.
Videos are a lot more challenging.
So that's one of the first
things we've been thinking
about is how we can incorporate
audios that people can listen
to the books while they're reading.
The other things we've
been talking to,
a company that's created
software that lays over the book
and analyzes the texts and then
creates, generates question--
comprehension questions
at the end of the book.
So that's another way that we
could support our readers, again,
not replacing librarians or teachers
or our community partners but,
you know, support readers as
they're using the software,
using the library to actually
gain basically literacy skills.
Does that answer, some of
what you're thinking, yeah?
Thank you.
>> Pamela Jackson: Great.
Next question, questions here
and who is your question of?
[ Inaudible Remarks ]
>> So question for the group
from Aotearoa from New Zealand?
>> Pamela Jackson:
Where is-- oh, back.
I'm sorry.
I couldn't find where Niki went.
>> OK. I just Keora [assumed
spelling] and so welcome.
I just want to ask
how you are working
with Maori on your initiatives?
>> Pamela Jackson: So, oh.
>> Nicola McCartney: Yes, we're on?
>> Pamela Jackson: Yup.
>> Nicola McCartney: Thanks
for the question Keora.
Maoris, regardless-- the
[inaudible] group I've represented
without literacy in New
Zealand, and so there are
at many special initiatives
that are happening in addition
to the mainstream initiatives
that we have.
So there are different things
for Maori-Pacific tribes
training for example.
The specific professional
development for educators
of Maori and for Maori educators.
So, the [inaudible] world is very
lively and it's a different one,
again a symposium being held
around the country as well.
So, represented at the moment
through literacy Aotearoa
and through Ako Aotearoa if you
know both of those organizations.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
No. No, the New Zealand government
decided that even though we started
in 2005 or 2009 at the national
scene, not 1963 is approach--
[inaudible] but in 2009, we started
as literacy language and numeracy.
And by 2011, the language had
come out and have been substituted
by the umbrella literacy.
And so done in English.
We question that, we
don't-- we don't actually--
Maori is an official
language of the country,
so it's a political issue
right at this very moment.
Thank you for raising that question.
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank you.
Time for one more question.
But we've also set a time
for one-on-ones too, so,
was there one last question we
should entertain for the big room?
Yes? So is the microphone
back there?
And who's your question for?
>> My question is for library for
all, although there might be some
of the other organizations
that could,
some of the other people
chimed in on it.
But, I'm Judy from SIL International
and you mentioned specifically
mother tongue books are the
most in-demand.
And there were a couple
other presenters
that alluded to the same issue.
I'd love to hear from you.
But, I am wondering what are you
doing for those language groups
for which there is very,
very little written.
What are you doing to find
them and resolve that issue?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Push up.
>> Allison Kavanagh: I would shout
but I think I have a quiet voice.
OK. And I'm happy to pass this
over to any of the other speakers,
because a lot of us were talking
about mother tongue content.
As you know the recent research from
UNESCO, shows that if children learn
to read in their local language
first, they're much more likely
to gain literacy in the
language of instruction.
And this is being the
kind of brain wave really.
Things that educators
and librarians have known
for a long time is now
proven in the research
and it's impacting the sustainable
development goals impacting USA,
these are agendas they look
to solve this challenge
of 250 million children not
learning how to read and write even
after four years at school.
So, you raised a good question,
the biggest challenge that we face
in our work is the
content supply chain.
So, those students at our program
in Cambodia have read through all
of the content in Khmer
and it's very challenging
for us to get more content.
It's the biggest challenge, and
I won't say that we've solved it.
And that's why we're starting to
have some of these conversations,
bringing all the groups together,
let's have some round tables
about this, because it's not
something we can solve alone.
We actually pay local publishers,
a license fee for their content.
So we license content.
You know, normally that should be
the role of the National Library,
right although Ministry of
Education to license content,
that will be available nationally.
So, we need to think
beyond that model.
I have a crazy idea that we could
use the part of the community
in crowd as my colleague
at Rumie said.
What about if we could create
a platform that would enable us
to crowdsource this content.
I was speaking to a colleague at
the Department of State yesterday
who did something similar for
film so he open up this platform
and invited people
from all over the world
to submit content for
a film festival.
He had since September 1st
he's had 1400 submissions
of film short films show on
an iPhone from 90 countries.
And now of course the challenge
there is quality, right?
Because we don't believe
in putting a lot
of content that's not
good on the library.
We have a very strict QA process
with a content advisory board
that reviews that everything.
We only have 3,000 titles on the
library for that reason of quality.
But, is there something
that we can do where we can
at least generate this supply
of content from the Diaspora
from individuals living
in these countries
and then create a system
to edit that content?
So, we invite all of you to
come and talk to us about this.
Maybe you want to work with this
on that idea or have another idea
because we-- it's a really
huge challenge and something
that we need to work on and so.
>> Pamela Jackson: Alright, good.
Thank you.
And we have one last-- Dan you want
to take the last question
or are you responding?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yeah. Yeah.
Anya's bringing the microphone now.
This will be our last discussion
point then we'll take a break
and we'll have a couple
of house keeping items.
Go.
>> Dan Wagner: So, I really
appreciate this last set
of comments.
It's certainly central to a lot
of the discussions that take place
at the UN around sustainable
development goals and so on.
I think that one of the things
that came through when every one
of the presentations today
was how important was to focus
on which target population
you're talking about.
Whether it's kids or it's
adults or it's in Khmer or it's
in French or it's in Creole.
But I think in the space where we
are now, I would say to my point
of view, we have to be even more
careful about our target population.
So that-- I especially I say
this to my friends who work
in the IT sector which I also do.
When you crowdsource, it greatly
depended on who that crowd is.
And that crowd is not
necessarily able to know
which target populations
are the most in need.
Really it's a little bit to
Timothy's question earlier about,
"are you teaching literacy
or are you simply providing
content-- library content?"
And I think to my mind, you know,
this is a group of people many
of whom care a lot about Literacy
and we're still working on the field
and investing a lot
of time and energy.
I think we need to as a group
make sure we know where we--
where our compared advantage is.
But also, be careful
not to over claim.
That happened, you know, years
ago when I started in this field.
You know, if you-- you felt
like if you were a good person,
that was good enough that anyone.
Remember the old phrase,
"Each one teach one".
Those programs did not work too well
because each one wasn't really
able to teach the other one.
Because there's a lot missing.
We are very limited
in our own skills.
And even crowds are
limited in their skills.
So just a point saying, there is a
lot of really great work to be done.
And so, I am impressed by all
these different initiatives.
I'm just asking for us to be even
more careful as we move forward
about which groups we think can
benefit from which approaches
that we're able to deliver.
>>Pamela Jackson: A strange advice.
Thank you.
And it's perfect for a post-it
on my white board in the back.
So make sure you guys
contribute you ideas there.
So let me say thank you.
I think that it is our goal, it
is our mission here at the Library
of Congress with the Literacy Awards
Program to know who's out there,
what are they doing,
and who they're serving.
And then to make sure
that they know each other.
Some of you already do.
Some of you are making
new friends today.
It's clear that there are
comparative advantages
that you all have.
That you are developing.
They're profound and very
significant and remarkable.
And we're very glad to be
able to know more about you.
To have you be with us and to
share amongst this community.
I would like to take this moment to
do a couple of housekeeping things.
So we are going to break lunches--
lunch will be available at noon
and so the set up for
that is going to start.
We do have certificates to give
to our best practice honorees,
so we'd like to do that
now and take advantage
of the time for a quick photo up.
For those of you who need to take
a break-- remember there-- the--
you can feel free to do that while
we actually ask the honorees to stay
for their certificates and
reconvene here at noon.
We do want to do--
make sure you remember
to do a couple of things though.
Write your reflection note.
Think of your other questions.
We invite you to sit
somewhere else for lunch.
Meet somebody new.
And give us your post-it note
feedback at the back of the room.
Also remember that
there are some displays.
Some of the organizations will
be available to share more
about themselves at
the display tables
in the room that's adjacent to us.
We're calling that LJ 113 it's
also the Woodrow Wilson Collection,
so you can browse the
books in there too.
They're behind closed
glass door there.
So at this time, if I
could do to ask Ricardo
and Anya to come and help me.
And then we'll have the honorees--
we'll call you out and
ask you to come forward
to receive your certificates
and stay for a group shot.
And I need your help
if you could stay.
Is Shawn [assumed spelling]
here, Shawn Miller?
OK Ricardo and Anya
you can come on up.
Alright has everyone got their shot?
>> Yes.
>> Pamela Jackson: Alright great.
Thank you so much and
congratulations.
[ Applause ]
So thank you so much
for-- really it was--
been a fabulous conversation
thus far and a really great day.
We've been joined by some
new guests this afternoon
for the second half of our program.
And to kind of get our orientation,
I would like just to take a moment
to acknowledge again
who's in the room.
So if I could for a moment have
the best practice honorees stand
and let's acknowledge them in their
presentations and contribution--
contributions this morning.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
And we have our Board of Advisors
to Literacy awards program
and the honorees that
were-- the individual--
the organizations that
were selected were done
so with the selection communities
that spent an enormous amount
of time and dedication.
So I'd like to acknowledge
you all and have you stand.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
And again, I mentioned
this morning we are--
I'm Pam Jackson, I should
have mentioned that,
Director for the Center for the
Book and Chair of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards Program.
And we are a part of the National
International Outreach Unit
at the Library.
And with us-- with us from the
national international outreach unit
are Jane McAuliffe our Director.
Colleen Shogan our deputy director.
Wave hello.
And Eugene Flanagan,
National Program.
So, thank you for being with us.
[ Applause ]
And I just-- I just want to
re-reiterate there is just--
it's absolutely perfect that we have
the international and national scope
that we have in the room.
From Afghanistan to Brazil
to New Zealand to Canada
and then throughout the
states here in America.
It's just the most fabulous
conversation we've had
and it continues.
So, let me now t urn to our
afternoon guest and to say,
it is my privilege and my honor to
introduce the Librarian of Congress,
Dr. Carla Hayden to join us and to
welcome us to the afternoon program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: And good afternoon.
And this is truly a joy for me.
I hope that you have
enjoyed your lunch
and getting to meet each other.
This is such an impressive group
of people who are gathered from all
over the world to celebrate literacy
and to really recommit to the idea
that learning to read as
Frederick Douglas said,
will make you forever free.
I extend my congratulations
to all of the winners
and the best practice honorees as
well as the extraordinary members
of the Literacy awards
advisory board.
Could you guys stand up again?
This was a hard thing for you to do.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And of course, we can't thank David
Rubenstein enough for his generosity
in creating these awards
and supporting it for
the past four years.
He is a true reliever
in the power of word.
He has not only created this program
but has also been the
primary supporter
of the National Book Festival
which was successfully held
for the 16th time this month
with more than 120 authors
and over 100,000 attendees
in one day.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now, you'll also know that he
is very generous doing something
and being present.
And that's giving his time.
So please join me in welcoming here
today, Mister David Rubenstein.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: Well, thank
you very much and welcome everybody.
It's my pleasure to be here.
As some of you probably
know, I grow up in Baltimore.
And in Baltimore, the public
libraries called the Enoch Pratt
Free Library named
after Enoch Pratt.
And it was that library that
I got my first library card.
And when I was I think in the 5th--
or in five or six years old that
they had a system there maybe--
where you can go to a library,
you get your library card I
think when you're five or six.
But in the system they had in
Baltimore, then you can only take
out I this it was 12 books a week.
So I would go and take my 12 books
and I would read them the first day,
but I have to wait to the
next week before I can go back
and get more books.
So, it was like conversion
process, but it worked out.
And because of that, I was able
to, you know, learn the importance
of reading and I appreciated it.
And it's probably that love of
reading that maybe made me be able
to do what I've been
able to do in my life.
So, I'm trying to get back a bit
by trying to get other people
to enjoy reading particularly young
people, but people of all ages.
And I am devastated when
I read the statistics
about how high the illiteracy
rate is in United States,
depending on how you look at it.
Roughly one out of seven adults
is functionally illiterate.
And how-- we have an addition
to the illiteracy problem,
the alliteracy problem which is
that people can read don't read.
So, something like 30%
of people that graduate
from college don't read a
book the rest of their life
which is not a good
commentary on our country.
So, I hope that what we can do by
getting the Library of Congress
as supportive as possible behind the
literacy movement and has been very,
very actively involved in--
for the last number of years,
we can use the Library of
Congress as extraordinary brand
and its great resources to let
people know in the United States
and around the world that
literacy is something that all
of us have an obligation
to do something about.
And all of us really should
pitch in and do much more
than we have done today as a society
and as a country and as a world
because if we're going to have
a great world, we really need
to have a world where
people can read.
If people can't read, progress
and civilization should have
isn't really going to be advanced.
So, I'm very disappointed
that it is the case
that there isn't enough resources
really for literacy movements.
Literacy people, all of you, are
always scrambling to raise money.
And it's very difficult if you
take a look at the great gallows
that are done in fundraising in the
non-profit world and I'm involved
in a number of organizations
that do this.
When you have performing arts, you
can raise a fair amount of money
around performing arts easily.
You have famous people show up when
you have e vents around art museums
and galleries, they're
important as well.
I like them, I'm involved.
But they get-- you get
the most famous people
in United States showing up and
the big wealthy art collectors.
When you have big events
promoting literacy,
you don't usually get the A
list of most famous people
in the United State
showing up you say,
how much money can
I give to literacy?
And why is that?
Well, they don't know about the
problem as much as they should.
So, I think it's incumbent
upon those of us who believe
in the importance of
promoting literacy
and avoiding illiteracy
and alliteracy.
We should do much more and redouble
our references, I will try to do.
So I want to just thank all
of you for what you are doing
to help this part of
our society learn more
about the problems we have with
literacy and alliteracy and try
to find ways that we can use
our combined intellectual
and financial resources to make
sure people recognize them.
When they talk about the
most important problems
in the country, they
talk about this.
So in the presidential
campaign for example,
no candidate in the primaries
or in the general election
has mentioned literacy
as a problem, nobody.
Nobody has mentioned illiteracy,
nobody has mentioned alliteracy.
Now, some might say one
of the candidates should
focus on that more.
But whatever you might believe,
I do think it's a sad situation
that we have roughly one seventh
of our adult population is
essentially illiterate and
yet we don't talk about it
in the presidential campaign.
There are a lot of
important problems.
But I hope we can put
on the national agenda
so you can see the words coming out
from the president of United States
at some point the importance
of literacy
and how we can do much more in that.
So, thank you for everything
you're doing
and I hope we can work together
to make this a more
important invisible cost.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: I
got to give you a hug.
>> David Rubenstein: Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
Thank you, Mr. Rubenstein.
We all needed to hear that.
And now, we will hear from the
three recipients of the Library
of Congress Literacy Awards
starting with the winner
of the American Prize,
Parent-Child Home Program,
represented by Sara Walter.
Now, you may know that the
Parent-Child Program has more
than 50 years of success
in educating parents
to develop school readiness in
children with disadvantages.
Their work has been replicated
in 400 high-need communities
in 14 states and Chile,
Canada, Ireland, and Bermuda.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
>> Sara Walter: Thank you.
So, I feel like I need to start
by saying I haven't been working
for them for the whole 50 years.
But I actually had the privilege
of taking over from the founder
and creator of the
model 19 years ago.
So, I have been there to
watch the program grow.
And I think before I tell you a
little a bit about the program,
I do want to start by saying one of
the things I think is most important
about literacy and I want
to echo it, the library
and Mr. Rubenstein
said is that it opens
so many other doors for families.
So, people talk about
Parent-Child Home Program
as an early literacy program.
But really, it's an
early math program.
It's a social-emotional
skill development program.
It's a graduation program.
For the children in our program,
this is often the first
graduation not just in their lives,
but in their family's lives.
And what it leads to is high school
graduation and college graduation
and other wonderful things.
So, I'm going to tell you a
little a bout how we do that.
So, our vision is a world
where every parent has the knowledge
skills and materials that they need
to get their child ready for school.
And that means to make sure
that their child has the
language literacy, numeracy,
and social-emotional
skills they need to walk
into a classroom successful on that
very, very first day because we know
that that's when we can have
the most impact and we know
that children who don't get those
tools before they enter school are
going to have harder and harder
time catching up the later
that we're able to bring
any of those services
to them and their families.
You all know, I'm preaching
to the choir here,
you all know about
the challenges that--
in this country and
in other countries
that very low income immigrant
and refugee families face their
children have heard 30 million
fewer words.
And I want to note, it's 30 million
fewer words before they turn four.
So Pre-K is a wonderful thing and
everybody should have access to it.
But it doesn't solve this problem.
In order to get kids to have heard
30 million more words before they
turn four, you have
to work with them
and their families before
those children turn 4.
So, that's our goal.
A little bit about who we work with,
so you'll get some
context for the program.
We're working with about
7,000 families nationally
across the country, 14 states.
I think the most interesting thing
about those families
is who they are.
We're a home visiting program.
We're going into people's homes.
But what we're doing is
really enabling families
who are the hardest to reach to
access programs and services.
So, home visiting is an
amazing program to work
with homeless families because
we can reach those families
when they're in shelter and we
can follow them wherever they move
over the next two years.
It's an amazing program to reach
immigrant and refugee families
because we can train staff who
speak those family's languages
to go into their homes.
And we can talk later about finding
the materials in their languages
to bring to them because I thought
that was a great discussion
this morning.
As you can see, 80% of the
families we work with are living
on incomes of $25,000 or less.
Think about what that
means in this country.
It means really they're
struggling to make ends meet
and they're not able to buy the
kinds of books and educational toys
that a middle class child in
this country sees everyday,
that children who are in really
quality preschools and early--
and childcare see everyday.
That's why we bring these
materials into the homes
and their gifts to the families.
One of the changes in our program
over 50 years is that now 63%
of our participating families,
the parents were born
outside of the United States.
We are doing the program every year.
And on average, 32 different
languages around the country.
The languages in our
database are over 50
of the languages we've served
families in the last 19 years.
So the model is the
guts of the model.
Two visits a week of a half a hour,
half hour is the attention span
or even more than the attention
span of a two or three-year-old.
That's' why the home
visits are pegged with that.
Also the families that we're
visiting have a lot of demands
on them, a lot of challenges.
And so, helping parents see that
reading, talking and playing
with your child can happen in
very small doses across the day,
the week, the months, the
years and make huge differences
for your child is a
really important message.
They get two home visits a
week, two cycles over two years,
the two-year-old and
the three-old-year here,
total is 92 home visits
over the program.
That's a lot of contact
with families.
So we really see and can document
the change that we're making.
The families get the
gifts of books and toys
which are a critical
piece of the program.
We leave them with them
as opposed under programs
which may bring materials
in, but then take them.
It doesn't do the family any good if
that book doesn't stay in your home
and become an integral
part of your daily life.
I think the other really important
fact before I show you some voices
or show you some families
from the program is that 25%
of our home visitors across the
country are parents who went
to the program as parents and
are then trained and hired
to be the home visiting
staff at our sites.
That's how we serve families
speaking 32 different languages.
And also is the other wonderful
part of the program which is
that it has a workforce
development piece for communities.
And the deeper we get
in communities,
the more former parents were able
to hire and the more the community--
the program can grow
and reach more families.
This is sort of the circle of the
things that we do in the program.
I think the most important
things are these cultural
and linguistic match and the fact
that the home visitors are not
only bringing these literacy tools
and modeling for parents
how to read, talk,
and play with their children,
they're connecting these families
to other services in
their communities.
Our goal is to reach families who
are not connected to other services.
And so, the goal of the home
visitor's work is not only
to model literacy, but to make sure
that the family has a medical home.
That if they just got an eviction
notice, we've connected them
with someone who's going to help
them with that, that they have heat,
that they have appropriate clothing
for the weather, all of the kinds
of challenges that the families
were working with experience.
And here are some voices
of parents in program.
[ Music ]
>> Amira: We were new to the
area and the home visitor,
she come to our door and
tell us about the program
and what benefit it has the children
to be ready when they go school.
>> Thuy: We learn how to
play with her, to show her
and read the book to
her every night.
That helped me a lot too.
I'm not really good teacher though.
>> Paula: It was hard
in the beginning
because he wasn't putting attention.
And now when he know
that she's coming,
he's already getting books
for her, bringing toys.
>> Thuy: She's can count 1 to 10
like that and write the letter A, B,
C. The more that we read the book
to her, she draw the picture.
>> Amira: I was worried
because Hanan is--
have a problem of hearing.
So taking to the school
was a big deal for me,
so like will she behave properly.
But the teacher said, wow, she
is ready, she know how to read
and she know how to behave with the
other children and then she said,
it's like she's been the school.
>> Sara Walter: So somebody
was talking earlier today
about empowering parents.
And I think you can see from
that that a critical piece
of this program is these
parents who are empowered.
They become advocates
for their children
as their children move
through school.
We have a former board member
who was actually a child
in the program 30 years ago and
he talks about how his mother used
to talk school and tell them
weren't giving him enough homework
because he was finishing
it too quickly.
He didn't appreciate it then.
But after he graduated
from law school,
he realized she'd been right.
Just to get back to we try to
bring in the books for families
and their native languages
not always possible.
We do something that
maybe the publishers
in this room should
cover their ears.
But if we can't find them in their
native language, we translate
and the language-- the
native language gets taped
into the book next to the English.
If you publish them in all 32
languages, we would buy them.
It's a relationship-based program.
It's about building the relationship
between the parent and child that's
so powerful for making
that child feel successful
and that parent feel successful
and I'm being told I need to stop
so I'm going to close with
it's starts with families,
but that's what makes
better and stronger schools,
better and stronger communities,
and a better and stronger citizenry
which is what we're all aspiring to
of kids who love reading and parents
who love learning and are empowered
to make sure their kids can.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you Sara.
And next, we have the award
winner of the International Prize,
Libraries Without Borders,
represented by Allister Chang.
Libraries Without Borders supports
communities in more than 20 nations
in a variety of ways including their
signature program the Ideas Box
which is an amazing portable
classroom, media center and library.
They can be assembled in 20
minutes, and I've seen it.
They are an innovative
organization using libraries
and related technologies to
bridge gaps in social, economic,
and political environment.
Congratulations.
Come on up.
There he is All right.
>> Allister Chang: --
Be with you all today.
I will also start with
a quick story of my own.
My parents immigrated to the
US and worked in restaurants.
And for me, the library was the
bridge between the Chinese home
that I had and the American
English speaking world outside.
And for me, the library has been
so important in shifting my life
to be the first person in my
family to go to college and be able
to choose what kind of
life I wanted to live.
I'm here today to tell you
about Libraries Without Borders
and specifically about the Ideas
Box which was earlier mentioned.
And the story begins in 2010
when I joined the organization
and we were working
in Haiti at the time.
And after a 7.0 magnitude earthquake
that destroyed the library
that we had hoped to build, our
local partners asked us to stay.
And at the time we asked ourselves,
is this really the right
time to rebuild the library?
Should resources not first to be
spent on food, water, and shelter?
At the insistence of University
of Haiti, we went and we worked.
And it was in this project that
we learned an important lesson
that shaped the story of
our organization's future.
Informational tools and spaces are
critical for disaster relief efforts
and should not be relegated
for many years later.
In humanitarian contexts,
we often focus
on basic needs, food,
water, shelter.
But we saw on the ground was
that people need more than that
in order to build their futures.
Our library in Haiti became a hub
for community leaders, engineers,
and aid workers to
reference reliable information
and to develop collaborations.
Today, Libraries Without Borders has
expanded upon that what we learned
in Haiti to leverage informational
tools for disaster relief,
peace building, entrepreneurship,
and economic development,
and the foundation of all
that is literacy programming.
Recognizing our work with internally
displaced persons in a Haiti,
we received requests from partners,
from UNHCR in the African
Great Lakes first.
And that's where we started to
continue the story of the Ideas Box.
And so, does anyone here know
what the average length of stay
for a refugee in a campus today?
Shout out some numbers.
Oh. There's supposed
to be a question mark.
[ Laughter ]
Ruined the surprise, but it's, you
know, whether or not you-- it's a--
this number is-- for us,
was heart breaking to learn
that this is the length of
stay for an average refugee
in a protracted crisis today.
And when-- you know, when we first
started this work, people said,
what-- exactly what we had asked
in Haiti at that time which was,
is this the right time
to this kind of work?
And they said, you know,
these are temporary spaces.
If it's 26 years, we're
losing generations of kids.
They're no longer temporary spaces.
So today, you know, there are
over 65 million refugees and IDPs.
And UNICEF recently
estimated that there are
over 28 million child refugees.
For us, it was to address
this challenge
that we approached Philippe
Starck, the French designer,
who worked with us to design a kit.
And he said to us when he agreed
to help us that he wanted to--
he was engaged by our mission to
not only help people stay alive,
but actually help them to live.
And so, we built the Ideas Box
which is a pop-up multimedia
center unpacked in 20 minutes.
That is fully autonomous,
portable, and durable.
And we have a quick video to show
that explains what this box does.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
So for us, most of our
work is with local partners
to customize all the Ideas Box
contents including paper books,
eReaders and dozens
of educational apps.
And each Ideas Box
serves 10,000 people
and quickly becomes
a learning center,
a library, and a community hub.
After 30 months of experimentation
in the humanitarian context,
we have had qualitative and
quantitative evaluations done
that demonstrate the impact
of the Ideas Box in education,
community building, and
psychosocial support.
The first two units of the Ideas
Box were implemented in Haiti
where we registered 24,000
visits in three months
and around 3,300 unique users.
A few months ago, we conducted a
quantitative study assessing the
educational literacy
and numeracy outcomes
of the Ideas Box through NRCT.
And it showed a 23% higher
average academic improvement
in the test group compared
with the control group as well
as increased curiosity
and participation.
We recognize the importance
of replicating the study
in different contexts and
with larger sample sizes.
But, you know, this initial
result is interesting
because it helps us claim
the impact of the Ideas Box
and how it exceeds
the sum of its pieces.
We're learning how educational
outcomes are not just the result
of the quality of teacher and
the quality of curriculum,
but also the quality
of the physical space.
And teachers have told us
that moving their class
to the Ideas Box classroom has
fundamentally shifted dynamics
between students and
fostered group discussions
and more interactive
learning opportunities.
And it is with sharing the results
of the program with refugees
that local governments and
libraries began suggesting
that we run programs and other
contexts including in The Bronx,
in Saxel, in France and
in Queensland Australia.
In the US, we partnered with
the New York Public Library
to create pop-up library
spaces and Laundromats
where we facilitated storytelling
and literacy workshops for children
and resume workshops for
adults who are waiting
for their laundry to wash and dry.
We've also partnered with the
National Library Colombia recently
to leverage ICT tools for peace
building in the rural areas
that have been most affected by
last 52 years of guerrilla conflict.
And my time is up.
And our next step is to formalize
micro entrepreneurship models
to sustainably grow
the Ideas Box program.
We have 70 in the field right now.
And our goal is to
build 1,000 by 2020.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Wow.
Thank you, Allister.
And finally, the winner
of the Rubenstein Prize,
Reading Rockets represented
by Noel Gunther.
Reading Rockets was created
by WETA to address the need
for evidence-based resources
among literacy providers,
educators and parents.
Their website is accessed nearly 6
millions times a year by parents,
teachers, and caregivers in need
of literacy resources and all
of the resources are free.
Thank you Reading Rockets
and congratulations.
Come on up.
[ Applause ]
>> Noel Gunther: Thanks
so much Dr. Hayden.
Thanks to you Pam Jackson, all
of your colleagues at the library
and Mr. Rubenstein for this award.
We're enormously grateful.
My parents were immigrants too.
That's seems to be theme today.
And everything they accomplished
and everything I've been able
to do really began with one
thing which was learning to read.
At Reading Rockets, we look at
how young children learn to read,
why so many kids struggle, and most
important, what can we do about it.
I'll tell you our story
in just a moment.
By that, we like to
start with a video clip,
a short clip from a documentary
we produced for PBS called "A Tale
of Two Schools" narrated
by Morgan Freeman.
We spent a whole year inside two
struggling elementary schools.
One in Mississippi Delta,
and one in Fort Worth, Texas.
And here's how the show begins.
>> [Background Music] Shhhh.
I'm the teacher.
>> This is Tavares.
He's starting first grade
in Fort Worth, Texas.
He needs to learn how to read,
but he's already way behind.
>> He will probably struggle
for the rest of his life
if we don't work on it now.
>> Meanwhile, in Sumner,
Mississippi,
rookie teacher Jill Todd
faces her own challenge.
Trying to teach reading in a setting
where almost every child
needs a lot of help.
>> I'm worn out, just
extremely tired.
>> And the superintendent
is at the end of his rope.
>> So, hell, if they won't give us
decent books, how are we supposed
to improve our test scores?
>> Across the country,
schools are struggling
with their most basic job,
teaching kids to read.
We spent an entire year inside
two schools that have known a lot
of failure and are now
trying valiantly to improve.
>> There are a lot of
times I want to quit.
>> I think we alternated
between chaos and limbo.
>> All kid can learn.
All kids can be successful.
>> What does it really take
to turn our schools around?
And what happens if we fail?
>> These kids deserve better.
And if these kids don't
get an adequate education,
they will not do better.
[ Music ]
>> Noel Gunther: That
year changed my life.
And that short his captures
the three-core ideas behind
Reading Rockets.
First, too many children
are failing.
One third of our fourth
graders scored below basic
on their NATE test which means they
can't understand a simple story
or they can barely read it all.
That just can't be OK.
Second, teachers are overwhelmed.
They want to do a great job,
but they often they
don't have the knowledge
or the support that
they need to do it.
And third and most important, we
know how to solve this problem.
The federal government alone has
spent more than 2 billion dollars
on reading research and
we know it's not easy.
But if we follow that research
and if principles, teachers,
and parents can work together,
almost every child can
become a proficient reader,
and that's where Reading
Rockets comes in.
Reading Rockets is
all about solutions.
We start with the best reading
research and then we use the power
of media to show step by
step what each of us can do
to help kids be more successful
as readers and writers.
As a media company, we do
everything in all our power then
to build a big audience and to
spread the words to parents,
teachers and everyone else who
touches the life of a young child.
When we started Reading
Rockets, my first question was,
why do many kids struggle
with reading?
It turns out that our brains are
hardwired to master spoken language.
Almost every child
learns to speak just
from being exposed to oral language.
But we've only been
reading for 5,000 years,
just a blink of an eye
in evolutionary terms.
So to become a good reader,
you need to take brain circuits
that were originally designed for
spoken language and then rewire them
to handle the printed word.
And for many kids,
that is really hard.
And because it's so hard to learn
reading, it's also hard to teach it.
Poor readers can be very
different one from another.
You need to diagnose the problem
really carefully before you can
solve it.
Teaching reading is rocket science
said researcher Louisa Moats.
And we see the best teachers,
they're great diagnosticians
and may have a whole range
of strategies they can use
to meet the kid-- needs
of individual kids.
I saw all this firsthand
with my younger son, Aaron,
who seemed to have everything going
for him when he started first grade.
Good vocabulary, lots
of background knowledge,
hundreds of hours spent
listening to stories,
and trust me unlimited
energy and enthusiasm.
But none of that seemed to help
him when he got to second grade
because his reading
was getting nowhere.
And one night in our living room,
he threw a book up against the wall
and he said, "I hate school" and
he started to cry and it was one
of the most heartbreaking
moments of my life.
Thanks to Reading Rockets, I was in
an unusual position and we were able
to find a great tutor who
figured out Aaron's problem
and then worked diligently with him
for almost a year until
it went away.
But the sad truth is that Aaron is
an exception and the great majority
of kids who fall behind in
school never managed to catch up.
So, what can we do to help
solve the reading crisis?
We started by asking the experts.
It makes researchers and skilled
teachers knew the research insight.
And now, they've spent a
lot of time in classrooms.
We now offer engaging
in-depth interviews on video
with the country's top experts
sharing their knowledge for free
with anyone who comes to our side.
We've also compiled a big growing
library of top-flight articles
about teaching and reading.
We start with really basic
information because we want
to welcome everyone into the tent.
But we also get very
detailed and granular.
So if you're concerned about a
second grader who's still struggling
with her short vowel signs,
we have good detailed
answers on Reading Rockets.
And we try to present all that
information in plain English
with a minimum of jargon
so everything is accessible
for beginners and experts alike.
I think most important--
And we just don't talk
about good teaching, we show it too.
We produce a dozen shows
for PBS highlighting the
most important elements
of teaching reading.
With host like Vivica Fox, Al Roker,
and Henry Winkler bring
it all to life.
On our website, we offer dozens of
video clips showing real teachers
and real classrooms working with
real kids, nothing scripted.
What they all have in common
is knowing how to teach well.
Teachers tell us all the time,
I want to see kids who look
like the ones in my classroom.
So we spent thousands of hours
filming pretty much everywhere
in the United States in schools who
serve African-Americans, Hispanics,
English language learners, kids
with disabilities the full range
of children who make
up the American Mosaic.
We've created online tools like this
one called, "Looking at Writing"
which gives teachers
a lot of guidance
about teaching writing effectively.
So we take real stories of
kids have written for school.
And in case you're not a first
grade teacher, this one is all
about a penguin and a leopard seal.
And then, we annotate almost
every line, tell parents
and teachers see what the child is
doing well where he or she needs
to improve, and then how to help
that child take the next step
towards becoming a good writer.
Just last month, we launched
something called "Reading 101",
a free introductory online course
to give teachers in grades K
through 3 a solid systematic
look at the basic principles
of teaching reading effectively.
We hope that this first course
will be a prototype for entire set
of courses about teaching,
reading, and writing.
It will be readily available
to every teacher in the world.
Our goal is to create a service
that's engaging authoritative
video-rich and free of
charge for everyone.
This is really an ambitious project.
And if we're able to
raise the money for it,
I think it'd become
our signature service
and the best long-term
legacy of Reading Rockets.
I'm hearing the bells, so
I'm going to advance quickly.
We have tip sheets in 11 languages.
And they make a huge difference
for the huge number of
kids in this country.
I just wanted to say when we started
Reading Rockets, we didn't know
if anyone will be interested.
We started with about
1,000 users a month.
We're up to about a
million users a month,
9 million users in
the last year alone.
And beyond that audience,
beyond that numbers,
is a connection we make everyday and
every night with worried parents,
worried teachers who can't
sleep because they're worried
about that kid at home who's just
not getting it done at school.
So, I want to thank all of
you, best part of the day
for us is having a chance to meet
with the groups around the world
and see if we would be
able to work together.
I hope we have a chance to
do that during the break.
And If you like to
get in touch with us,
there are e-mail addresses,
just come up and say hi.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: Thank you,
Noel, and congratulations to all
of the award winners and honorees.
We really appreciate
everything you do.
Now, we're going to have a
discussion, an interview,
with the winners with
Mr. David Rubenstein.
And afterwards, I think
there will be time for you
to ask some questions
and think about things.
So please join us on the stage.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
So, I should've said at the
beginning when I was talking
about the Enoch Pratt Library, I
didn't quite finish the thought.
That is the library obviously that
Carla Hayden headed for number
of years and did a great job there.
And we are very appreciative
that she has come to Washington.
And I'm very happy that she has
embraced the literacy cause.
She obviously was involved
with it before.
But it wasn't a foregoing
conclusion.
The Library of Congress would,
you know, adapt this cause.
But I very much appreciate
the-- her doing so.
So Libraries Without Borders,
do Doctors Without Borders asked
for like a royalty for
that name or did they--
where did you get that name?
Did they ever call you up
and say we have that name?
>> Allister Chang: The word
on the street is that Lawyers
Without Borders is one
of the organizations
that didn't ask for
permission before.
[ Laughter ]
>> David Rubenstein: So,
what is your annual budget?
>> Allister Chang: Five
million Euros right now.
>> David Rubenstein:
Five million Euros?
>> Allister Chang: Mm-hmm.
>> David Rubenstein: All
right, and your annual budget?
>> Sara Walter: So for the
supporting the programs
around the country,
it's about 20 million.
>> David Rubenstein: Twenty million?
And your annual budget is?
>> Noel Gunther: The Reading
Rocket is about $400,000.
>> David Rubenstein: Really?
Wow. OK. So, well, you got a big
boost in your budget, I guess.
>> Noel Gunther: Thank
you so much, you noticed.
>> David Rubenstein: So in
your observation, all of you,
if parents cannot read,
what is the--
is there a likelihood that
the children cannot read?
For example, when you go into
try to get parents to be involved
and the parents can't read, isn't
the child had a big disadvantage,
and how do you overcome that?
>> Sara Walter: So, yes, they're at
a big disadvantage because parents
who have very low literacy
levels often think
that they can't prepare
their children to be literate
and for school success,
but they can.
And one of the things
that we show parents is
that you can picture read
a book with your child
and have a conversation that's
rich in language and imagination.
Two-year-old doesn't know if you're
reading the words on the page
or you're just having a
conversation with them.
The one thing I would say is we find
that that process is
the perfect link
for then getting the parent
excited about starting
to learn to read themselves.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
So, let me ask you-- all of
you, is this your career?
In other words, you're not going to
go become a private equity investor,
hedge fund investor
in a couple of years?
This is what you're going to
be doing or if you thought
about doing it for a while
and then doing something else?
>> Allister Chang:
This is my calling.
My focus before this,
have been in human rights.
And if you dig down
deeply into the root causes
of what human rights abuse is--
are and where I was
working in Southeast Asia,
it comes back to access
to information.
>> David Rubenstein: So, did
your friends say you should go
to Wall Street and
be hedge fund person
or people would say,
why are you doing this?
Or you ever get that question?
>> Allister Chang: Absolutely.
I think that those questions come up
and it certainly not the
most lucrative industry.
But time back to what I was saying
before, I think what is beautiful
about the space that I've been able
to inhabit because I was able to go
to college is that I can
work in a career work.
I do what I love and survive
by making enough money--
>> David Rubenstein: Where did
you go to college, United States?
>> Allister Chang: I went
to grad school at Harvard.
>> David Rubenstein: Harvard?
>> Allister Chang: Mm-hmm
>> David Rubenstein:
What part of Harvard?
>> Allister Chang:
The Kennedy School.
>> David Rubenstein: I know that.
>> Allister Chang: Yes.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
So, what about you?
Are you going to-- this
is your life, your career?
>> Sara Walter: This is my life.
I'm a lapsed lawyer.
And I do get asked-- and the
most striking thing is people
who don't understand that this
is actually a real full-time job
that I've been doing for
19 years and I consider it
as are more important
than being a lawyer.
But the number of people who think
that if you work for a nonprofit,
you must be volunteering or
experimenting with something outside
of the workforce is
very interesting to me.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
And what about you?
>> Noel Gunther: I also was a
lawyer, but I recovered quickly.
[ Laughter ]
I spent five years doing that.
But that was a lifetime's worth.
And this work is so
much more meaningful.
>> David Rubenstein: You don't
think that we'd be better off
if we have one more lawyer?
>> Sara Walter: Two more.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
So, I'm curious, how many
books a week do you read?
>> Allister Chang: Oh, three, four.
>> David Rubenstein: Really?
>> Allister Chang: Yeah.
>> David Rubenstein: That's a lot.
What about you?
Can you read three or four a week?
>> Sara Walter: I can't read
three or four for a week, but two
and a lot of other print, I still
read newspapers and newspaper forum.
>> David Rubenstein: Yeah.
Me too, I'm the last person
running around carrying newspapers.
So, I know--
>> Sara Walter: I'm with you.
>> Noel Gunther: I'd
say one every two weeks.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
So today, would you say
that the biggest challenge
for literacy effort is that
the people don't realize
that problem exists
as much as it does?
What-- When you tell people
there's a illiteracy problem
in this country, do all you find
that people look at you quizzically
and say what are you
talking about or not?
>> Noel Gunther: Oh, absolutely.
I think people have no idea
because the illiteracy problem
is a hidden problem mostly.
I came to education as a total
amateur which was a disadvantage
in some ways where I got to visit
schools with completely clear,
unprejudiced and the
overwhelming fact of education
in the United States is that it's
all about class and the people
in power have kids going to good
schools and they're thriving.
And if the kids aren't
struggling, they find a way
like I did to get help for my kids.
But everyday, we sit and we
allow kids in poorest schools
to get a crummy education to start
off unequal and have fewer resources
and we just accept
this as a fact of life.
And so, it's-- the
problem is hugely prevalent
and still largely hidden problem
to the elites, the policy makers,
the people in the academy.
It's just something they
don't see themselves
>> David Rubenstein: Right
>> Noel Gunther: And so,
they don't care enough.
>> David Rubenstein: Yes
>> Allister Chang: And
then, in the international--
[ Applause ]
Libraries Without Borders
is part of the group called
"The Global Campaign for Education".
And their recent analyses have
shown that 2% of international aid
that was spent from the US goes
into education work at all.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
>> Allister Chang: Right.
So, that for us, this is a big
policy shift that we need to think
about and bringing literacy work
into the broader aid
that we provide.
>> David Rubenstein: So, what
extent if you don't have parents,
let's suppose you-- your parents
are deceased of you're taken away,
you have a guardian or something,
to what extent are
you a big disadvantage
in learning how to read?
>> Sara Walter: Well, we do our work
with anybody who's the significant
adult in that child's life.
So, we work with grandparents who
have custody of their grandchildren,
with foster parents, with guardians,
with aunts, uncles, older siblings,
whoever is the person who
could help bring literacy
into that child's life.
>> Noel Gunther: One-- I'd like to
add something which is, you know,
we at Reading Rockets mostly
focus on the real basic job
of teaching kids to read, how
do you do that effectively.
But I think what our
schools are missing
and our society is often
missing is that you have
to teach the whole child.
And there are kids who were
coming to school, they are hungry,
they were up all night, they're
in unstable environments,
they're in a homeless shelter,
they're not having good healthcare,
their tooth is hurting and
that's all they can think about,
and we behave as if those
things aren't impediment
to learning whereas if any of
our kids were in that position,
we would want to get help
for them immediately.
And so, one of the most
hopeful things that I see
in education is the movement
towards community schools,
to providing wraparound services
for the whole family and for the kid
so that when the child is in school,
he can actually think about school
and the teachers could do the job
they were actually trained to do.
>> David Rubenstein:
So frequently, I--
when I'm watching public
broadcasting which is all I watch
of course public broadcasting,
when I watch it
and there are these efforts to raise
money, probably you've seen them,
they go on TV, they raise money from
time to time, I never hear them say,
give us-- give me money for Reading
Rockets, why don't they do that?
>> Noel Gunther: Please
talk to Sharon.
[ Laughter ]
>> David Rubenstein: Like
they don't mention that.
OK. Well, I hope they
mention it to her.
But it seemed like a good
idea to raise money for it.
So, literacy in the United
States, we're a wealthy country
and people presume that we
would be pretty literate,
but literacy as we've talked
about isn't so wonderful.
But is it actually worse in let's
say take Sub-Saharan Africa,
I don't know if you're
familiar with it.
But is Sub-Saharan Africa much worse
or let's say Southeast
Asia, is that much worse?
Or where is it really
worse than United States?
>> Allister Chang: You know, United
States is a country of extremes.
We have the most highly educated
and also I think some of the least.
And we've been-- I've been
particularly interested
in doing more work on Native
American reservations.
And on the Lakota Sioux tribe for
example, you know, literacy aside--
and I think this is a
piece of it talking back
to what you were saying, it's
the second lowest mortality rates
in the Western Hemisphere
there after Haiti, right?
And that's in the United States.
And so, I think that
in those contexts
and the White Mountain
Apache reservation
where we've been working,
some of the teachers told us
that literacy rates, you know, we
need to talk about what this means
and what the statistics
are behind this.
He was talking about
then about this.
But they said less than
10% of the kids, right?
And I think that's lower than a lot
of the refugee camps
that we work in.
>> David Rubenstein:
So, let me ask you,
let's suppose you are
from a wealthy family.
Your parents are pretty wealthy and
let's suppose they both have PhDs.
The chance of you being illiterate
is zero, more ore less or not?
>> Noel Gunther: I wouldn't say
zero because there are some kids
that have a genuine
brain-based disability.
And it's really hard for
them to learn to read.
And there are also a lot of kids
who are kind of teaching casualties.
Or teachers, we don't really respect
the dignity of a teaching profession
as much as we should
in this country.
And so, a lot of teachers
are not really prepared.
So if they find a kid who
doesn't get at the first time,
they may not know what to do to
help that kid, wealthy or not.
>> David Rubenstein: What
percentage of children that you deal
with would you say have dyslexia,
and they can't read because of
that problem as opposed to the
other things we've addressed?
>> Noel Gunther: It's probably
3, 4, 5, 6%, in that range.
There's no perfect
test for this dyslexia,
there's no blood test or biomarker.
But that's what the
best research suggests.
>> David Rubenstein:
More in boys than girls?
>> Noel Gunther: Not especially.
>> David Rubenstein: All right.
>> Noel Gunther: Boys
are more noticeable
because fidgeting and acting out.
Girls tend to be a little quieter.
>> Sara Walter: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
And do you think illiteracy is a
higher problem in the United States
in rural areas or in urban areas?
>> Sara Walter: I don't know the
statistics off the top of my head.
But I will tell you
from our experience,
it goes back to what Noel is saying
about, it's high poverty areas.
So, very low income
families in rural areas
and very low income families in
urban areas are actually just
as isolated, have low
access to services.
And if the parents have
limited literacy in either
of those communities,
they're less likely to go
out and seek those services.
>> David Rubenstein: The most
literate state in the United States
by literacy standards is?
>> Noel Gunther: Massachusetts
maybe or Connecticut?
>> David Rubenstein: I think Iowa.
>> Noel Gunther: Iowa, OK.
>> David Rubenstein: Iowa.
What's the least literate?
>> Noel Gunther: Got
to be Mississippi.
>> Sara Walter: It's
got to be Mississippi.
>> David Rubenstein: All right.
It's probably right.
OK. So, let me ask you a problem
that I have talked about before
that is not a function of
what you're really doing,
but I'm interested and so
I'm going to ask you about it
which is the problem of alliteracy.
So, it turns out as I was
describing before that people
who actually can read
choose not to read.
And when they do read
something, they read,
you know, something not a book.
They might read something
less than a book and so forth.
Why do you think so many people
who are college-educated
can enjoy their life or feel
that they can enjoy their life or
have a happy life without reading?
Do you observe this problem very
much in your literacy efforts?
I know you're focused
on those things but--
>> Sara Walter: Well, I
would just pass it that--
and I'm sure you have
more to say on this.
But then, many people educated
in our education system whether
they're wealthy or not don't--
aren't given a love of reading
because they're given uninteresting
materials to read in school
that don't make you want
to pick up another book.
For our families, what we find
is if we can build that bond
so that parents and children
discover the joy of reading together
that the greatest thing is sitting
on your parent's lap
and reading a book.
That lasts.
That child is a child that
goes into a classroom and runs
and grabs a book because they
associate books with warmth
and happiness and interest.
So, I think we have a lot
of work to do to grow people
who aren't alliterate
and really love reading.
>> David Rubenstein: I would
say in that regard, it was--
we gave an award last year,
I can't remember the
name of the organization.
But it was a very creative idea
where it turns out if you read
to your children, that's a
good thing as we all know.
But if your-- let's say, your father
is away or your mother is away
and they're serving the military,
there was a program that they have--
on a video screen, they have
the father or the mother reading
in their uniform to their child
who's watching them on TV.
It seemed that'd be a
pretty creative idea.
I assume that kind of thing
works the best, right?
>> Sara Walter: Yes, absolutely.
>> David Rubenstein: So today, why
do you think, as I said earlier,
no politician running for president
of United States mentioned
this issue?
They forgot or they
don't know about it?
>> Sara Walter: Because the people
who experienced this issue are
not the people they're talking
to when they're running for office.
They're people they don't think--
>> David Rubenstein: The donors
are not focused on that, right?
>> Sara Walter: No.
>> David Rubenstein: And how would
you propose that we get it to be
on a higher part of
the national agenda?
>> Sara Walter: Well,
in part, it takes people
like you talking about it.
>> David Rubenstein: Oh.
>> Sara Walter: I think
that's critically important.
[ Applause ]
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
So today, I'll do what I can.
>> Sara Walter: I know you are.
>> David Rubenstein:
Some candidates,
I'm not sure they read the books
that much themselves, but OK.
What would you say is the thing
that motivates you the most
to get up everyday and do this?
Is it that do you think you're
making a difference in the world
and is that why you're
so interested in this?
>> Noel Gunther: Let's say
having spent that year in Texas
and Mississippi ever since
and those kids are kind
of living rent-free inside
my head and I can't get them
out because I think about them.
So, that's the sort of mission part.
And the other part is
working in media is fun.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
>> Noel Gunther: You know,
so we're creating content
and reaching the audience.
It's really intriguing.
Intellectually, it's
a challenge everyday.
>> David Rubenstein: Now, do your
family say to you, why don't you go
out and practice law and make more
money, they don't ever say that?
>> Noel Gunther: No, [inaudible]
same compulsions that I have though.
>> David Rubenstein: All right.
OK. OK. So in your case, this
is going to be your life's work.
But what is the greatest
gratification you'd get?
What is it that makes you feel so
great when you come home at the end
of the day and what kind of
thing happens through the day
that you actually find
the most gratifying?
>> Sara Walter: It's the success
stories from our families or going
to a site and having parents tell
you how this changed their life
or going to a graduation and
a little girl comes up to you
with the stethoscope from the
doctor's kit that we brought in,
she knows all the names of
everything in the doctor's kit
and she tells you that
she's going to be a doctor.
And not only she can be a
doctor, she can be the first child
in their family to graduate
from high school before
she gets to being a doctor.
That's what keeps me going.
>> David Rubenstein: All right.
So let me ask you, that video
that you showed earlier,
that take about 24 hours to do,
you did it in a time-lapse, right?
How long do you really
take to do that?
>> Allister Chang: Twenty minutes.
>> David Rubenstein: Twenty minutes?
>> Allister Chang: Mm-hmm.
>> David Rubenstein: And do you
have to train people to do that
or go to school to learn
how to do that or--
>> Sara Walter: It's
a degree at Harvard.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
Is that that hard or?
>> Allister Chang: So for the first
implementation, it takes an hour
or so for everyone to work
together and figure it out.
And then as a couple of
weeks pass, everyone--
>> David Rubenstein: And
how many of those exist?
How many--
>> Allister Chang:
We have 70 right now.
>> David Rubenstein: Seventy?
And what do they cost
to manufacture?
>> Allister Chang: Twenty thousand.
>> David Rubenstein: $20,000?
>> Allister Chang: Mm-hmm.
>> David Rubenstein: And you can--
you ship them or how
do you get them?
>> Allister Chang: Yup.
So, part of this is thinking
through the supply chain, right?
So, we started as a book
donation organization
and books would get wet
during transportation.
They'd have no security when
they-- or storage when they arrive.
And then once they do
arrive, they're not integrated
into the broader education system.
And so, this was a way for
us to think through all
of the different supply
chain challenges including
the transportation.
>> David Rubenstein: The young
children that you often deal with,
what percentage of them do not
have access to the internet?
And therefore at home,
they don't have a computer.
They don't have access to it.
So, they're not learning to read
on the computer the way
some people are now.
>> Allister Chang: I would say
that beyond access, it's a question
of accessibility too, right?
Because especially we're seeing this
in the areas where we're working
and where you're getting access
to internet for the first time,
often those users will believe that
anything on the internet is true
or than that's even worse, for
dealing with misinformation.
>> David Rubenstein:
You mean, it's not--
[ Laughter ]
I thought everything was.
OK. It's not, OK.
All right.
>> Sara Walter: I would
say at least half
of our families do not have
regular access to the internet,
certainly not in their homes.
And even if they have a smartphone,
they don't always have the data plan
because they can't always afford it.
So, assuming that they're going
to be able to get to content
without us helping to
facilitate it is a challenge.
>> Noel Gunther: I know
starts are about right.
And so, we really focus on
working with teachers and all
of the professionals to
touch families as opposed
to necessarily feeling would
always find the families directly.
>> David Rubenstein: The best source
of raising money for you is who,
business people or people feel
guilty, they're not in the business?
Who is it that you get
to raise most money from?
>> Allister Chang:
For the Ideas Box,
it came from the Soros Foundation.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
>> Sara Walter: Primarily,
private foundations.
Although we are getting in
several states like Massachusetts,
states dollars, that
help support the program.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
>> Noel Gunther: We
got some big grants
from the Department of Education.
But now, we're supported
by foundations
and we make some money
online from Goggle ads.
>> David Rubenstein: And do
you feel the US government
when they give you money, they
make it too easy to get it
because the forms are, you
know, easy to fill out?
Is that a problem--
>> Noel Gunther: That
was the biggest thing.
I felt guilty.
>> David Rubenstein: And
what about foundations,
are they easily get money from
because their forms are easy?
>> Allister Chang: No.
>> Sara Walter: And all the same.
>> Noel Gunther: Right.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
Yes.
>> Allister Chang: I think
that's why we're trying to think
about social enterprise
model, right?
In Burundi, the users have
been charging folks who come
in to watch a movie at the box and
hoping to pay for operational cost.
And those are kind of
the models we want to--
>> David Rubenstein: Let's
suppose the next president
of United States called you up
and said, I don't really know much
about your problem, I'll give
you, you know, 20 seconds.
Explain to me everything I
need to know about your problem
and what I should do about it.
What would you say?
>> Allister Chang: That
literacy is not incorporated
into disaster relief or any
international aid work that we do
or enough international
aid work that we do.
And that we have-- through
supply chain challenges
to be able to provide it.
>> David Rubenstein: And what
would you say to the next president
of the United States about what?
>> Sara Walter: That the only way
we're going to solve the illiteracy
and high school graduation issue in
this country is by reaching children
and their parents before
they enter school.
>> David Rubenstein: What would
you say to the next president?
>> Noel Gunther: I'd
say we can solve this.
And if we don't solve this, we can't
really effectively address any other
social problem.
So, we better solve it.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
OK. All right.
So, any questions from people?
Anybody have any questions?
Questions?
Don't be shy.
Whoever asks a question
will get a grant.
So--
>> Sara Walter: Oh, wait a
minute, I have a question.
>> Thank you.
And congratulations to
the three award winners.
So, I work for USAID.
So, we do most of our programing
overseas and other countries.
And the lessons from the examples
of your projects I think are
completely replicable and something
that we could use internationally.
But I wanted to ask you as sort of
a panelist of a literacy specialist,
how replicable do you think
your activities are in terms
of big challenges, simply not having
enough materials and local languages
and how would you address that
if kids don't have materials
and languages which they could
read, it's hard to have that as one
of the building blocks of their
future's success in reading.
So, I just wanted to
have your reactions to--
or the projects that you're working
on, Allister, maybe you can talk
about open education resources
as a source and materials.
Thank you.
>> Allister Chang: Well, open
education resources and to add
to that too I think the--
one of the beautiful things
about a library space and
informal education spaces is
that they are also opportunities
for people to create content,
not just access them, right?
And so for us, a lot of our programs
are built around involving students
to help build that database of
content available in the community.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
Yeah.
>> Noel Gunther: We have
another website called "Colorín,
Colorado" which was actually
started because of user demand.
A lot of people came to
Reading Rockets and said,
I know how to teach these kids, but
what do I do about English learners?
And in most of the countries I
understand that you're working with,
the language of instruction
is different from the language
that the kids are speaking at home.
So, you absolutely have to
start with the native language.
And that I think the
principles that we try support
on Colorín are applicable to any
second language learner in the world
which is now most of them.
>> David Rubenstein:
So, let me ask you this.
Right now, the Nobel Peace Prize
has never been given for literacy,
though you could argue that maybe
they would give one for literacy.
So, which person around the
world do you think has, honestly,
over the last 20, 30 years done the
most to help the literacy movement?
There must somebody
who you would say
as a role model for
you, or you, or you.
Is there anybody that you think
has done such a great job?
>> Noel Gunther: I have one nominee.
His name is Reid Lyon and he
ran the reading program at NIH
for about 15 or 20 years.
And from this middle level of
position in the government,
he wound up being the
most influential person
in setting reading polls.
And he has inspired so many people
in this country including me,
I don't know, the worldwide
situation as well.
But he is a hero to me and
many, many other people.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
Any other candidates for
the Nobel Peace Prize?
No? All right.
Do you have a question?
>> [Inaudible].
And with the STGs for instance.
I mean, we've taken step backwards.
We're going-- You know, literacy
is no longer the priority.
We no longer make education for all.
We're talking about substantial
proportions of the population.
How do we-- I mean, if we can't even
persuade, you know, the government,
how-- if the international-- the
global orientations for education
and literacy aren't powerful enough,
what sort of law we can change the
way the world thinks about literacy?
>> Allister Chang: So, I mentioned
the Global Campaign for Education
that they have three staff and
they're a lobbying group, right?
And that's it.
Well, there's a few other groups.
There's an idea that is starting
to float around within these spaces
that I've been having
conferences at of where's the money
and how do we frame this work
to able to access that money.
And I think the purists would find
this to be less more offensive.
But can we think about
literacy as a way to fold
into countering violent
extremism and other places
where there is a lot of money
being set aside for right now.
One of our camps Welcoming Centers
in Europe, our facilitator called
and said, you know, ISIS
is actively recruiting
on site at the Welcoming Center.
I can work with 60 people.
There's 400 people
here, what do I do?
And we can only work with so
many people at any given time.
I think that there's
a direct link there.
And I'm curious to see how we
can work as a community to go
where the money is as well as
pull more money into this space.
>> David Rubenstein: So, OK.
Question? Yes.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Get her a mic.
>> Right here, right here.
Right here.
Here.
>> Thank you.
One of those things that
we're trying to do at--
through UNESCO right now
is something called the
"Global Alliance for Literacy".
And the major tenet of
that is to take literacy
out of the education ghetto.
Literacy cannot be the property
of the education departments.
We know too well that literacy is
essential for the economy, for jobs,
for the jobs [inaudible]
for the recent meeting.
I read an article on the Wall
Street Journal that said in Ohio,
there's always unemployment
of white-collar workers.
And they said there were
these factories that had jobs,
but they couldn't fill them because
people didn't have the skills,
literacy and education, then
this health, health care.
How people are going to be able
to provide healthcare
if they can't read?
And let me add, I know we're
talking about the children.
But, you know, there is no such
thing as a child in poverty folks.
They were children who
have the misfortune
of living with poor parents.
And if those parents
can't read and write,
they're not going to
learn earn a living.
So, let's think of those children
in the context of their homes
in the communities and
make sure the parents
and the communities get
these skills they need.
>> David Rubenstein: What-- OK.
What was the most influential
book you ever read or book
that influenced you
the most, any book?
>> Allister Chang: Toni
Morrison, "The Bluest Eye".
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
What was the most influential book?
>> Sara Walter: I'm going
to say it was Little House
in the Big Woods because--
by Laura Ingalls Wilder
because that was the book that
made me love reading and enabled me
to read all the other
books I've read.
>> Noel Gunther: My kids would
kill me, but it was [inaudible].
>> David Rubenstein: So,
let me you all a book story.
Maybe some of you have
heard me say this before.
My-- I own a-- partner
at a private equity firm.
And a number of years ago,
we've bought a company
called Baker & Taylor.
Some of you may have heard of this.
It's the second largest book
distributor in Unites Sates.
It started in 1839, and had
not made a profit since 1839.
We've bought it.
It was always break
even and so fort.
I think it was second
to Ingram at that time.
And one day, a salesman came
into our board meeting and said,
I found a new way to make
money because distribution
of books isn't that profitable.
But somebody came in
and said that he wanted
to rent our bibliography of books.
Now, the biggest bibliography
of books
in United States is no doubt
owned by the Library of Congress,
but they don't sell
that bibliography.
So, we owned the second
biggest bibliography.
And this person said he was--
he wanted to rent it from us.
And he wanted to give
us a third of a company.
He was starting to sell books.
And our salesman is saying, why?
Wait a second, we're not taking
stock in a startup company.
We're too smart for that.
Give us some cash.
So, they negotiated a
deal, $100,000 a year
for five years and then we rent it.
OK. A couple months later, I read
about a company being started
in Seattle, I think
it was called Amazon.
And I said, wait a second, maybe
they would like to rent this too
because they're going to
sell books on the internet.
So, I called up the salesman and
said maybe there'll be another idiot
that would pay $100,000
a year for something
that doesn't cost us
anything, it's free money.
He said, no, that's the idiot
I already did deal with.
So, I said oh, OK.
So, I read a little bit
more about it and I said,
maybe this company is
worth more than I thought.
So, I went up to see Jeff Bezos.
And I said, you know, our
salesman, he made a mistake, he--
we're really lucky to be
a third of the company,
and we don't want this
$100,000 a year.
He said, I don't think
I need you quite
as much I did about a year ago.
But you were helpful to
get me off the ground.
So, I tell you what I'll do,
we'll tear off the contract
and I'll give you a stock in
our company and he gave us 1%.
We didn't have confidence in the
company, so we sold it at the IPO.
That stock is now worth about
four and a half billion dollars.
So, anybody got a more
heartbreaking story about books?
So, I would have more
money to give to literacy.
But-- So, let me ask you a
final question, if I could.
Today, as you look at the
world of literacy and so forth,
what would you say the world
of literacy, those people care
about this need to do that
they're not doing and talking
to the Congress or talking to the
public or the business community
or the president of the United
States to kind of make this seem
like it's a more urgent issue
than some people think it is.
What would you recommend
that the people
in the literacy world do
to kind of elevate this?
>> Sara Walter: Well, I want to get
back to your comment because I think
that the fact that all of these
folks out there who were trying
to get literate and reading are
the workforce of the future is one
of the most compelling
arguments we can make.
And actually, the place where we've
been most successful in growing,
we now serve 1,200
families a year in Seattle
because the Seattle
business community more
than any other business
community in this country looked
at the literacy rate and the
high school graduation rate
in their county and said, 20
years from now, we're not going
to have a workforce unless
we start investing it
in families and children and young.
So I think if all of us could get
together and speak with one voice
about how important this is
for the future of our country,
that would be the most
compelling argument I can make.
>> David Rubenstein: All
right, any additional comment?
No?
>> Noel Gunther: I would say
come and see for yourself.
You have one hour to give me, don't
spend it in your office or mind.
Let's go visit a school.
But I'm going to pick the
school and no cameras there.
>> David Rubenstein:
And do you books online
or do you actually
get the physical book?
>> Noel Gunther: I still read-- One
more thing about influential book,
"The Cat in the Hat",
the original disruptor--
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
All right.
OK. Allister Chang:
The-- Sorry, go ahead.
>> David Rubenstein: Go ahead.
Go ahead.
>> Allister Chang: Answering
that question and building
up of what you just said, the OECD
came out with a study that said
that we spend in the US 0.1% of
our GDP on job retraining programs
for adults who've lost their job
versus in other OECD
countries 0.6% of their GDP.
I think that there's a lot of
arguments to make especially
in rural towns in the US,
we haven't been investing
in folks who've lost
their-- still no jobs.
And that's creating a lot of the
anger and frustration right now.
Internationally, I'd just say
that, you know, in Europe,
we're learning firsthand that people
can walk from Syria to Dusseldorf.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
>> Allister Chang: They have been--
The borders are-- of the world are--
the world is much smaller
than today than ever.
And I think that especially with
now millions, over 50 million
of these families being
without literacy tools.
We are-- We're creating
problems for our future.
And that there's absolute
world need for us
to start dealing with that now.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
So final question, if each
of you could meet one writer
who has ever lived, who
would you like to meet?
[ Laughs ]
>> Sara Walter: F. Scott Fitzgerald
>> David Rubenstein:
F. Scott Fitzgerald
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Sara Walter: That's unfair.
>> Allister Chang: Oh, wow.
Well, you know, I've
been doing lot of reading
into whether Shakespeare
was a real person or not.
>> David Rubenstein: Right.
>> Allister Chang: And
what's interesting there is
that the purists in English will
say that the writer doesn't matter;
it's the text that's
important, right?
But I would love to
meet this Edward Burke.
>> David Rubenstein: OK.
>> Noel Gunther: I think I might say
Homer to find if he's really blind
and if he really could
write that much [inaudible].
>> David Rubenstein: Oh, OK.
Thank you very much for
great a conversation.
>> Sara Walter: Thank you.
>> Allister Chang: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Pamela Jackson: Wow.
So thank you so much Mr. Rubenstein,
and thank you to our prize winners.
This was a fabulous discussion.
We intended for this block of
time to actually continue the Q&A.
And what we hope to do-- am I on?
OK. And what we hope to do
is build on the conversation
that we've had both this afternoon
and this morning in
terms of the blend.
One of the things that we were
intending to do is kind of listen
for the themes and listen for kind
of where the threads the strongest
in the conversations throughout
the morning and the afternoon.
And one of the places
that I heard was the issue
of content in the native tongue.
And I know there are a
couple of different people
in the room [inaudible] which
mic I should be speaking
into in this moment.
There are couple different people
in the room who could speak to that.
And we'd like to find out if you
would like to that at this time.
Can you hear me now?
Which one?
I'm turning this off?
OK, great.
Thank you.
Bless you.
So, we wanted to find out if
there's an opportunity at this point
for people to pick up on the theme
about literature being available
in the common tongue and the
native language of the child.
I really-- I am looking
around the around the room
and I'm seeing people
that I've been talking
to over the last the few months
who were working in this area.
Some of the award winners
brought up the issue and others
who were actually working on it
haven't had a chance to speak.
So, we wanted to find out if that
is something that people would
like to do it as this time.
And this time was allotted
for more Q&A for us
to be dialoging with each other.
So, where're my mic runners?
Oh, there you are.
Ready? Yes?
No? Yes. I was hoping
you'd raise your hand.
Yes, Christie.
Thank you.
>> Christie Vilsack:
I'm Christie Vilsack.
I am the Senior Advisor for
International Education at USAID.
And I carry this with
me all the time.
And I know we have SIL here.
But USA and Tony spoke to
this a little bit earlier,
this is a little bit of magic
because this flash drive can be put
into any computer in the world.
And with a very short tutorial, any
of us in this room would be able
to start writing books for
children in local languages.
And I know some of the
recipients today are actually going
to be helping us do this.
We hope everybody will as we help
create The Global Book Alliance
because we are going to
create a digital library
in the Cloud open source
so that anybody
in the world whether it's a
domestic teacher or a librarian,
whether it's an international
parents, any place in the world
or teachers, any place
in the world will be able
to start producing books
in these local languages.
So, you can talk to me or Tony or go
online to USAID education or to SIL
or to World Vision or
just about anybody.
I know that one of our
best practices library
for all will be doing in Haiti, will
be helping us use the Bloom software
to start creating books
in local languages there.
And there are of peace out
there right now to our agency
for whole countries
to engage and figuring
out how they want to
meet these needs.
I've just come from
Rwanda and Malawi and Kenya
where for the first
time every child in all
of those countries will have
a book in the first grade
in their local language as well as
a book in English, and by next year,
second, third and fourth grade.
So, we're really working to scale
and we appreciate the help of all
of our partners in the room and
out there to help us get this done.
It may take us a while to have a
digital library with every book
and every language,
but we're committed
to doing it even those really
obscure languages it may be some
of us don't even know exist yet.
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank you.
>> Judy Cochran: I'm Judy Cochran
[assumed spelling] with the SIL.
And we developed the software
that she's talking about.
And I would just like to direct you
if you're interested to the website
which is bloomlibrary.org.
And if you want to remember
it, it's bloom because you want
to grow a library, bloomlibrary.org.
>> Pamela Jackson: Oh, great.
Thanks.
>> Judy Cochran: And I
was talking about SIL too.
But African storybook, there are
lots of [inaudible], there are lots
of other online products
that are helping us do this
and we will gather
all of them together
in the Global Book Alliance.
But that's-- Bloom software
is just one of them.
>> Pamela Jackson: Great, thank you.
>> Laura Bailey: Hi, I'm Laura
Bailey [assumed spelling] and I'm
on the Literacy Awards
Advisory Board.
And our Rubenstein winner
in the second year was an
organization called Room to Read
which works internationally.
And I remember reviewing
their information.
And one of the most impressive
things that they were doing,
they were working in many
different countries around the world
and they were actually teaching
local people to become authors
and illustrators and they have over
1,500 books that they've created
in 19 different languages.
I just went on their
website a few minutes ago
to get an update on that.
And so, my question and
challenge to this group is how
to leverage the expertise and the
resources created by other programs
that come to our attention.
How do we reach out to Room to Read
and see if we can build on the books
in native languages that
they've already created
that could be useful to all of us.
>> Pamela Jackson:
Allister, you want to respond?
OK, great.
>> Allister Chang: I think
it's a great question.
And to even push that
further, I think we're--
there's collaborations to
be made across our sector.
But last year, one of last
year's winner was also Kyle
from First Book.
And I-- what I think was really
interesting about their work is
that they're aggregating enough
buyers to be able to have leverage
to go to publishers to say
we need bilingual books
and we will buy 300,000 copies of it
if you publish the bilingual books.
And as a community, if we could
all get together and be that--
aggregate our purchases to
be able to have that weight,
I think we would have
something to show for it.
Yeah.
>> Pamela Jackson: Yes?
Anne [assumed spelling] is right
behind you with the microphone then.
>> At the risk of being a professor
which is a big risk in this crowd,
I know many of the people
who've been advocating as I have
for mother tongue literacy
materials, it's also the case
that the research is
not there that suggest
that just having mother tongue
books is-- are sufficient.
We have huge problems with teacher
training around multiple languages.
Most teachers are not
trained in mother tongue.
They're trained in
a second language.
They go out there and they don't
know how to teach in mother tongue.
There's also a huge issue that isn't
entirely visible for many people
who are producing books that has to
do with the pedagogy that is needed
to transfer from one
language to the next.
And if you have a-- Now I know that,
I would say historically
speaking, the world has turned.
We are finally focusing on mother
tongue materials and I'm not
at all questioning
the utility in that.
I'm saying that even with
open source materials,
even as good as we are going to
get, we'll be having meetings here
and hopefully prices here that
we'll look at the next step.
And the next step is actually harder
than producing mother
tongue materials.
It's how to implement a program
that can use one or more languages
in classroom where the teachers are
usually not sufficiently trained
and where-- and important
to say the politics
of countries are not entirely
clear on these issues.
In the United States or in Rwanda
or in the other countries mentioned,
there are many ministers.
I know-- I see some nodding heads.
I know that we have
nodding heads in this crowd.
So in spite of what we
would like to see happen,
the world is a more
complicated place.
And I would just say that, well,
let's keep our eyes open
beyond it maybe necessary
to have mother tongue materials.
I think it is but it's
probably not sufficient.
>> Pamela Jackson: Yeah, sufficient.
Necessarily but not sufficient.
All right, great.
Yes?
>> Good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Karina Polumn [assumed
spelling] with scholastic.
So, as I listened to this discussion
and as Professor said, it's--
the quality of the book is
going to critically important
in making sure we have
authentic text.
Because some books
are transferable--
I mean, when you translate them they
can work, but a lot of them do not.
And I worked with my counterpart,
that's in the international
marketplace and, you know,
translating some books
is really inappropriate,
so you have to be careful
of that happening.
But it is going to be critical to
partner with local organizations
and people who are producing
books and publisher to make sure
that we are representing
authentic text
that tells the authentic stories.
And as, you know, the
professor mentioned,
that's going to be critical to
that-- this idea of translation.
Because it's easier for us to
translation but it's not as easy
as we think and it doesn't
really represent itself
in those native tongues in those
countries as well as it's ought to.
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank you.
Yes, Sara.
Anne is-- They're both
coming at you.
[ Laughter ]
>> I just wanted to follow on that
because I think it's a
really important point.
One of the things that we find
is really important to have books
for very young children,
particularly when you're trying
to get them interested in reading,
that have children in them who look
like them and families
who live like them
and neighborhoods that
look like theirs.
And that's really important that
one of the things you might see
when you look at our curriculum
for our families is we used a lot
of books with animals, because
animals transfer in ways
that maybe stories
about people don't.
But-- And I also just want to--
I'm not going to argue with
the professor in research.
I'm a lawyer by training
and I know not to do that.
But I do want to say that mother--
there's another reason why mother
tongue materials are so important.
And that's because that's
what enables parents
to read to their children.
And regardless of what may happen
when that child gets to school,
is really important that parents
have material in the language
that they know and that they speak
at home to read to their kids.
And we do see that children who
have strong native language skills,
when they get to school, if they
have a teacher who knows how
to then teach them
the school language
in their community will
be able to transition well
to learning that school language.
But they have to be able to speak
and read in their native tongue,
to have a relationship
with their family.
>> Pamela Jackson: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
>> So, I have a question for folks
that are in a publishing area.
And I agree about the
authentic text.
So, I'm thinking about diaspora,
you know, about refuges et cetera.
So, you know, especially with
earlier comment about that sense
of culture and sense of belonging.
So, intuitively, it seems like for
those kids that are in those kinds
of situations as families
that they need materials
about their home country.
They need materials
about the culture
that they're now situated in.
And that they need stories about
other people like them who are
in that same situation of making
those changes or accommodations
or whatever in terms
of transitioning
or accommodating different
culture simultaneously.
>> Pamela Jackson: Is there--
>> Thoughts.
>> Pamela Jackson: -- thoughts?
All right, just dialogue.
So, one of the things--
another common theme I
heard today was this issue
about where does literacy live,
where does the policy issue live.
That's come up a couple of
times throughout the day today,
and this notion of is it by itself,
where is it in the
world of education?
And I hear a lot of threading
throughout in different ways.
I'm not at all going to start
the fight to say it belongs here.
Maybe not.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, but I heard--
I've heard this before,
like who owns literacy?
Is it really Department
of Education?
You know, should folks
stay away from it?
Does it belong by itself?
If it does, where?
It's a complement to
the education system.
The focus on it as a
complement to that system
versus integrated within.
I'm just curious to see if there's
more dialogue about that topic.
Yes? That's so funny
there're some eager hands.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Is he on?
>> Jeff Carter: Am I on?
Yes. So, I just want to say this
is the first time and coming
to these are always wonderful.
And I'm really happy that we're
talking a lot more about policy.
At this one that I
think ever before,
which I think is really important.
So, I'm Jeff Carter with the
National Coalition for Literacy.
I've worked in adult literacy
for a long time in policy.
I think the question--
to me the question
about where it lives
is not irrelevant.
But I think, again, it
comes down to priority.
If we made it a priority in this
country, that question would,
I think, simply sort
of resolve itself.
So, simply thinking-- I think it's
a mistake to think that, well,
if we're just situated here, it
will get the attention it needs
and it will take care of it.
I think it's actually a
more fundamental issue
around advocacy and awareness.
And I having had this experience
of doing a ton of advocacy here
on the hill around adult
literacy, I can tell you all
that there are too many
representatives up there on the hill
who knew nothing about the
work that you all are doing.
Nothing. And that's one
of our big problems.
Because I think policymakers want to
have to be able invest in success.
And it's one thing to put out
a problem but it's another
to actually be able to hold up
success stories that are investable.
And I'm also glad we
had the question
about replicability and about scale.
Those are really important
discussions to have as well.
So, I think it was Allister or
someone else made the point,
I do think it's important to
point out in terms of policy
that it is critical to many other
concerns that we have with--
particularly in terms
of addressing poverty.
So, in the discussion, I
think we need to situate it
in different places but in terms
of who owns it or who runs it,
that's probably down the list
of things that I worry about.
>> Pamela Jackson.
Kristy?
>> I'm switching hats now.
But I think that in terms of
policy in talking about Congress--
and I know this is the
Library of Congress.
But governors know these issues.
And I think if we're talking
about policy that we might think
about going to the governors of
this country because they understand
if it's an economic development
issue and they understand
that their workforces and
their individual states depend
on early childhood and
those three, and four,
five years before children
get in to school.
So, if we're looking at a place
where people, I think we have a,
maybe a welcome audience and
people who are little bit educated
about that that it might
be through those people
at the heads of their states.
And those are policymakers.
And when we went after early
childhood and quality daycare
and really engage the business
community and brought them together
to put pressure on the
legislator along with the governor.
So, it was both ends plus their
grassroots community going
out to every small community in the
state in making the case to parents
that this was in their best interest
and the best interests
of their kids.
>> Pamela Jackson: OK.
And just quick-- the pressure was
on what, funding certain kinds
of reading promotion
programs funding--
>> The result for preschool
for four-year-olds and quality
of daycare systems so the
parents can identify what kind
of daycare they want for their kids.
>> Pamela Jackson: OK.
Thank you.
Yeah.
>> I think along the
lines of policy,
it might be quite interesting
to keep an eye on the law
that was just passed in
the State of Michigan.
Michigan passed a law, a bit ago,
that if a child couldn't read
at third grade at-- reading-- grade
level by the end of third grade,
they could not go in school.
There was undue commotion,
there's still great commotion.
Some people are saying absolutely
that must be what happens,
other people-- even though the
law passed, there's, of course,
no resources behind this.
Now, we have all the
people with the-- who are--
who is being tested all
the emotional difficulties.
So, I think it's just
going to be so much fun
to watch how that plays out.
>> Pamela Jackson: Fun, really?
>> Because it also will give
us some insight into what kind
of policies can be passed and where
in the policy arena it can help
or where in the policy arena it
may hinder the growth of literacy.
It clearly denotes that the folks
know about a problem but we'll have
to see if policy at that level
improves the situation or does not.
So it's a place to keep an eye on.
>> Pamela Jackson: Well, I'm really
struggling with this because I am--
most of you, you all know, I'm new
to this particular job so I'm new
to this particular conversation.
I'm an economist by training
and I don't get how come it's
not a no-brainer the quality
of our labor force in
10 years, in 20 years.
I don't get how that's just not
completely and totally obvious
that if you don't put money here,
you're going to be pouring
out money over here.
I don't get it.
Help me.
[ Laughter ]
>> Liza McFadden: This
is Liza McFadden
with the Barbara Bush Foundation.
And I think you were
spot on and I think a lot
of what the movement I'm
seeing right now and goes back
to something you said, is
how we monetize the value
of literacy in the future.
We're starting to see there's
been two really successful
pay-for-success models in the early
literacy area in Utah, in Chicago.
And now there's a work by
Walmart looking at, you know,
there were two articles in New
York Times recently, about the fact
that they've upgraded the
training of their workforce
and they're seeing results.
And as we see that, and that
impacts things, like for example,
if you increased the literacy level
and then you have fewer accidents
in the workplace and
your insurance goes down,
you may start monetizing it
internally, and saying, OK, literacy
and training really matters.
So, I think it's-- and
really incumbent on all of us
to follow how this can play out and
how it can benefit the workplace.
And I think then we're going
to really see some movement,
both on the early childhood
and the adult education ends.
>> Pamela Jackson: OK.
>> I just want to add that
I think the Pre-K movement
in the US is a really
good example for us.
I just don't think it's gone far
enough or have been funded enough.
But as the part of education that
has made huge slips forward in terms
of the amount of public
money now being invested
and it's probably the best example.
And they did a really good job
of rallying unexpected voices
to advocate for Pre-K,
particularly at the state level.
And those would be generals
and admirals and police chiefs
and sheriffs, who started to talk
both about their workforce but also
about the fact that
literacy reduces crime rates.
If you look at our
present population today,
it is heavily people with
very low literacy levels.
So, when those are the folks who
walk into a public official's room
as opposed to me or, you know, that
the kindergarten teacher's saying
"But I need children to come
to school ready to learn read,
if I'm going to be able
to teach them free."
If when you have a general
or an admiral or sheriff go
into their representative's
office or their governor's office,
it's heard in a whole different way.
And I think the literacy
movement, we probably need to take
that Pre-K lesson and broaden it
out to make sure it's a much bigger
advocacy piece that we're doing.
>> Pamela Jackson: I'll
take the microphone here.
Thank you.
>> To get back to your question why,
because it's makes perfect sense.
And we've seen it makes
sense over and over again.
I'm much older than everybody
else in the room and I've been
through these different
iterations of literacy.
One of the issues has always been--
and Karen just articulated
over here.
There's been ideologically, if
you will, thing that's going
on where whenever we've been very
successful with literacy programs
and made sure the various context
that we taught the
literacy skills needed
to not just get the
GED but also get a job.
You have people who say "Oh,
no, we can't monetize literacy."
Literacy is a right.
Literacy is a human right.
If you just turn everybody
into a cog in the wheel,
and they're just there
for the economic reason,
you are violating some-- And
that conversation has obfuscated
to some extent to the point that
you made, of course it's obvious.
And there's a way of doing
both, of not negating the right
of human beings to learn to read, at
the same time loudly acknowledging
and constructing programs,
working with the workforce.
Because we did a lot of that stuff
in New York back in the '70s,
to get GEDs, get associate degrees,
and be trained to work Con Ed
and at the phone company
every place else.
>> Pamela Jackson: Right.
>> The other very big
area is health care.
There's-- We really need more
partnerships within the Health
and Human Services area because
there's an awful lot that parents
with kids missed-- and in
their own care as well.
We've story back from the '70s, we
had a meeting up at Colombia once,
and there was a woman who kept--
we heard a story from a doctor
that a woman kept showing
up in the emergency room
with diabetic attacks.
Over and over and over again,
they-- she come in, they treat her,
they've show her how to
and she end up there.
Finally, someone say, "We don't
understand, we've shown you."
And she said, "I do
exactly what you say.
I take an orange, and then I
shoot my insulin into the orange
and then I eat the orange."
[ Laughter ]
She couldn't read so she
couldn't read the instructions.
So the demonstration they were
using was what she thought--
>> [Simultaneously] -- was
what she supposed to do.
>> That's not apocryphal.
That was a true story.
So, we have to.
And lawmakers will hear it,
business people will hear it,
and I think we can do it in a way
that does not offend the people
that believe people should read
for joy and for the pleasure
for the Bible and everything else.
>> Pamela Jackson: OK, yeah.
>> We haven't succeeded
in doing that yet.
>> Pamela Jackson: Any international
commentary on this issue,
the whole literacy
investment and-- Yes?
>> Yes. But not as
straightforward as-- Am I on?
>> Pamela Jackson: Yeah.
He just says to turn
you-- You're good.
>> Yes. Thank you.
What we want is problem
solvers and critical thinkers.
So, how do we get there?
We need policy for that.
We need people who implement policy.
We need a joined-up approach.
And at New Zealand we've
had some strong initiatives
of being government-based.
Nothing is straightforward
and nothing is easy,
but there is a strong direction.
What we know in the workplace
is that if you are able
to align language with the CEOs, if
you are able to talk about measures
with the CEOs, if you're
able to put simple measures
into business aligned-driven
programs, then it's very easy
to say the difference that you make.
So, I spoke very briefly about
the whole organization approach
to literacy and numeracy
in New Zealand,
it's the same thing
in terms of a country.
And New Zealand's a great
country as an example to look
at because we only have
four million people.
And we have a lot of experiments
that comes to New Zealand
because it's a very cohesive
little place to come to.
I think New Zealand
is very interesting
on how we've taken the
literacy and numeracy approach
and how we are looking now,
some-- Since 2001, Diana,
when we first had policy that how--
we're not at the next stage
of joining the government
agencies together,
to really bring the next level of
implementation, and that we need all
of these initiatives that
people are talking about.
We need a good practice models.
We need the advocate efficacy.
We need the policy, we need the
practices, we need the systems,
all for sustainability
because we don't want
to keep doing this all the time.
No country anymore has
got the money to do that.
So, we need to be looking at
systemic and sustainable approaches
for literacy and numeracy.
Thank you.
>> Pamela Jackson: Yeah, yeah.
Down in front.
Thank you.
Do you have-- Angie, was there-- OK.
>> Louise Bridges:
Thank you so much.
My name is Louise Bridges.
I'm on the literacy advisory board.
And to the question we
need to monetize literacy,
literacy is monetized in ways that
are dangerous and are just adding
to the inequity in our country.
Many of you probably are familiar
with the work of Mariah Evans
at the University of
Nevada, who shows that books
in the home is the number one factor
in whether children succeed or not.
As few as 20 books in the home
can make a huge difference
in a child's life.
And we know that in our country,
we have what is now commonly
referred to as book deserts.
If you follow the work of Dr. Susan
Newman, she had a tremendous piece
in the Atlantic Monthly recently.
She looked at two different
communities in Philadelphia.
One high poverty; the other middle
class, in 2001 and found that 60%
of all children living in high
poverty communities have less than--
or have no books in the home.
She went back to that same--
those same two communities just
two years ago and it's worse.
It-- The problem is growing in
very frightening and scary ways.
So, part of this begins with
giving people a living wage
so that they can buy
books for their children
and have books in their homes.
>> Pamela Jackson: Got it.
And then, Timothy, you had a--
behind you with the microphone.
>> Timothy Ireland: And I'm being
on both sides of the divide.
I was-- I worked with this project,
which was awarded here the
[inaudible] school for 25 years.
But I worked from 1990 to
2004 coordinating the project.
And then I was invited to take a
post-ministry of education in Brazil
where I was responsible
for a national program called
Literate Brazil Programme.
In the Literate Brazil Programme,
we were responsible for something
like an average over 12 years of
1,200,000 people being attended,
I wouldn't say made
literate each year.
But I think the struggle is talking
specifically about adult literacy.
This is a complete mental
block in terms of investment,
and people who always think at
least in countries which I know best
that adult literacy can
be done on the cheap.
And I-- I mean, within
the same ministry,
we were investing something like
200, $300 a head for adult literacy,
whereas a child in primary
school is worth 2,500 or 2,600.
You know, what mindset is
it that permits you to think
that adult literacy is
worth so little compared
with a child's education?
When you know that if the
parent isn't literate, you know,
the child's education is
going to suffer even more.
So this difficulty of persuading
even progressive governments
to invest in real terms in
adult education is enormous.
And the other thing when you talk
about responsibility from literacy,
in our case obviously the
adult literacy program,
belong to the ministry of education.
One of the difficulties
is depending obviously
on how you define literacy.
In the case of this
particular program,
the literacy program
was eight months,
and you don't make anybody
literate in eight months.
But how do you guarantee
that the people who take part
in literacy programs, which is at
least a step into the written world,
how would you guarantee that that
person continues his studies?
And quite often, literacy programs
and adult education
programs are separate.
In our case, for instance, we had
separate funding to literate--
literacy program from the
adult education program.
So literacy programs, the classrooms
weren't physically in schools.
They weren't in community
associations,
or in other space is church-based
[inaudible] base or whatever,
whereas obviously adult
education took part in schools,
how do you bridge that divide.
So I think in terms of--
I don't know whether--
there are two different discourses
and two different problems in terms
of the developed countries and
the less developed countries.
But I still think that,
you know, persuading people
that adult literacy is fundamental
for all the reasons we know,
we prefer to talk about--
you know, I was interested
that nobody has mentioned Paul
Freddie [assumed spelling]
here today.
And I think that must
be an exception.
Obviously, there are other
people who have done a lot
for an adult literacy
besides Paul Freddie.
But Paul Freddie obviously has
been an important influence
on a lot of people.
But how to persuade, you know,
people to invest in adult education
for its economic importance, for
its importance of human rights,
for its importance, it's just
an essential right of everybody
to learn how to read and write and
to be more of a person as a result.
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So, we are close to wrapping
up this portion but I want
to make sure I gave chance.
Any final questions or follow-up?
I know that, you know, certainly
Timothy is speaking as one
of the best practice honorees in the
realm of literacy in a workplace.
And so, we certainly hear
an opportunity for adults
to be learning to read
where they are,
which is not necessary in school.
We just make sure-- There were
two other things that came
up that haven't gotten a lot of
attention and we can either put them
in a parking lot or see if you
want-- they excite you right now.
Numeracy and literacy.
And I noticed there's some
attention on numeracy.
Some folks have their
attention on it, mentioned it.
Some of it's on the background;
some of it's in the foreground.
Any comments there,
for future discussion?
And then the problem of illiteracy.
Diana, behind you with--
>> Diana Coben: Hi.
I would like to speak
up for numeracy.
Because I think for too long it's
been the poor relation of literacy
and subsumed within
it on my own, OK?
Yeah. And so I think
it's very important
that it's given due respect
and not subsumed within--
you know, deemed to be
covered by literacy,
both things are really important.
And just as an example, I was
very struck by a colleague
over there talking
about the Michigan law.
There was the amazing piece of work
done in the 1960s by the children
of the school of [inaudible]
in Italy,
which proves conclusively just
how damaging that approach is
of holding children
back year on year.
It was statistical work
done by the children
with their teachers are
absolutely outstanding.
A copy should go to
lawmakers of Michigan.
[ Laughter ]
And that's an example.
That's an example of numeracy
as a key element of education
and of being a critical and
fully functioning adult able
to command respect in their
society and command a living wage
and command a decent life.
>> Pamela Jackson: Thank you.
OK, a couple more comments.
And, again, just so you
know for our schedule.
What we have planned is
that a wrap-up no later
than 3:00 and then break.
For those of you who want to
do-- those that led tours,
they're going to start at
3:15, for those of you who want
to continue the dialogue here
or in the tabletop presentation room
back there, you're welcome to do so.
And then the reception
is at 4:00 downstairs.
Just so you know what's going on
for the rest of the afternoon.
Go ahead.
>> OK. Is it all right?
OK, OK. So, a couple of us have
noticed that there's been more
of the ICT and numeracy discussed
outside of the United States.
And in United States, I think, we
sometimes kind of separate those two
in a more-- you know,
the Venn diagrams are--
you know, don't overlap as much.
And I think also-- And
I'd be really curious
if in other countries
there's the same kind
of dismissal about numeracy.
In fact we don't even tend to use
the term numeracy as much in the US.
It's more like math
literacy, you know,
where folks will say, "Oh, math.
Well, you'll never need that.
And, you know, I never
was good at math."
You know, how many people would
self-disclose "Oh, you know,
reading, who needs reading?"
I mean, yeah, so I mean I think math
illiteracy is even more of a hidden,
you know, problem than
even, you know,
the reading and writing literacy.
But what I am noticing is,
you know, we talk so much
about data-driven decision
making and importance of that,
that I know that librarians
are now talking more explicitly
about data literacy, and that
might be a way a hook at being able
to then refrain numeracy.
>> Pamela Jackson: And then Paul.
Paul is ready, but after you Diana.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Does she--
OK, yeah.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Yeah, so let's switch--
Diana, switch with Anya
[assumed spelling] there, please.
Thank you.
>> OK. Did you hear that?
I was just saying that the
survey of adult skills,
which is on at the
moment OECD program
of the international
assessment develop competencies,
not only include numeracy but it's
a key in [inaudible] area together
with literacy and problem solving
and technology-rich environments.
That international survey
and the previous ones,
the adult literacy [inaudible]
school survey and the one before
that have been enormously
influential insofar
as there's a heck of a lot of
more work to be done, of course.
But in persuading governments and
business and other organization
of the importance of these skills
for adult life, and I would love
to see some better sort
of speech going on also,
the coordination going on between
UNESCO and OECD and these big sort
of super-national organizations
to get literacy, numeracy.
And so the whole digital piece
which is part of both those areas,
you know, raised up in sort of
public consciousness and, you know,
some coordinated policy
and ideas around that.
So, numeracy as I say
has to be at the table.
It's such a key area about the life
we know but it's one of the areas
which has a direct impact
on adult's chances in life
if they are low numerate
that's just as devastating
if not more or so than low literate.
>> Pamela Jackson: Paul,
you want to-- Thank you.
You, thank you.
>> Paul Austin: Paul Austin,
superintendent of schools.
And I think-- I'm listening
very carefully
because I think I'm the only--
Am I the only public
educator in the room?
I'm a little intimidated
and out of my element.
But I listened very intently
with what people are saying.
And there are a couple of
things that I'm not much of a--
I'm on a comment at a meeting
but I'm going to do it anyway.
There's a lot of things that were
said and I apologize if I'll go back
for a minute on some of the issues
that we're facing in public schools.
One is-- And I can't
remember exactly who said it,
about taking care of the
needs of the whole child.
I can't do anything.
I can give the best instruction
and provide the best professional
development for my teachers
and hire the very, very best.
I can't do anything if kids
are coming to school hungry,
they're cold, they're tired,
they're homeless, they have no work.
Those are the things that I would
encourage all of you to think
about when we think about how to
improve literacy in this country.
There is no doubt about that.
And I live in an area that 75%
of my population live in poverty.
It's 66% of the income, and say,
if the income of my area is 66%
of the national average income.
And so we're facing huge,
huge divides of a work we're
trying to accomplish everyday.
And I see it everyday because
I'm in the schools everyday.
It's one of the things that I pride
myself on and getting in there
and seeing what kids are doing.
And so I encourage you to bridge
the gaps between health care,
and insurance, and food
security, and home security.
That has to be done if we're
going to move anything.
I'm also curious about the numeracy.
And I agree, because we
haven't talked much about it.
It's interesting.
I don't know if other states are
like Maine, but we've had great,
great success in moving literacy
forward and not so much in numeracy.
In fact, all of our work
over the last decade--
and I can say I have three
decades in public school,
has a special educator, social
worker, school psychologist,
assistant superintendent,
and superintendent.
I've seen a lot of
different changes.
And so we've spent a lot of time
doing literacy and really thinking
about instructional literacy,
but not much on numeracy,
and that shows.
I won't even get started
on what I think
about state assessment
and national assessment.
Those things that they're doing in
Michigan, and my PhD is actually
in public policy, I'm
ashamed to say it sometimes.
But the ideas of what they're
trying to do in Michigan is not
about improving literacy
and numeracy in students
but in shaming America's teachers,
to show them that they
are not doing the job.
And that is a-- somebody
mentioned earlier--
and I think it was the
gentleman from Chicago or--
I can't remember where you're
from but close enough--
that talked about that
the profession
of teaching is not
getting due diligence.
Those are the things that I think
this group can influence greatly.
And we do appreciate all the support
that we get in public education.
So, thank you.
>> Pamela Jackson:
Yeah, thank you Paul.
Thank you.
That might be our last word.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, let me just
wrap up and say thank you.
This has been an extraordinary day.
It has been remarkable to have the
firsthand experience of the work
that you all are doing for the
honorees and the award winners.
The work that you're
doing is just phenomenal.
And I have to admit
that probably four
or five different times during
the presentations, I was crying
and just sad and want to like
ball up in a corner and just like,
"Uh just get-- " you know, this
is just overwhelming, right?
And then at other times in the
conversation there's so much hope
and inspiration and joy and
excitement and commitment.
So, certainly I'm in
a roller coaster ride.
And what I'm left with at the end
of the day is an extraordinary group
of people who are phenomenal
contributors to others.
Whether it's our advisers,
award-winners, our honorees,
Center for the Book staff,
Library of Congress staff,
friends of the Library of
Congress, former award-winners,
former honorees, you're all here
in the room in some capacity,
just the most remarkable people.
And I thank you for being here.
I thank you for being our partners.
Thank you for being
in this conversation.
I'm so glad you were here.
And with that, we'll
take a short break.
Time for dialogue.
Time for tours.
Four o'clock downstairs.
Time for drinks.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.